on a collé ses comics la waci comédienne
voici muriel robin la veille
les montois remet ça alors tout le monde
en parle l'héroïne du nouveau film de
mehdi charef s'appelle marie line ce
comme ce héros dans garde à vue comme
coluche dans tchao pantin vous passer
avec succès du comics je tue
programmatiquement fin au sérieux quoi
ça a bien démarré c'est bien oui c'est
bien c'est tellement inquiète la semaine
dernière non vraiment c'est un drôle de
truc que j'ai vécu je n'avais pas on
entend parler de ça le mercredi pour la
santé des films ça peu virtuel mais
quand arrive
l'été sur les champs-elysées à deux
heures de l'après midi j'hésitais g
tournicoter
finalement je suis allé on disait les
chiffres à oui c'est crevant à chaque
fois que vous répondez à une interview
que ce soit dans la presse ou dans là où
la télé ou à la radio oui toujours c'est
ma mère en parlant de marilyn vous dites
pour retrouver cette dureté j'ai eu qu'à
me souvenir vous racontez votre enfance
ça lui fait quoi faire quand même parce
que quand on touche pas elle gueule pas
quand elle vous voilà dans sa star
attend les huiles a parlé musique et
maman je suis désolé un raccourci que je
me comprendre mais c'est pas ma main
mais c'est vrai que je connais la dureté
ouais donc j'ai pas eu à me souvenir ce
que c'est avait de la dureté il y avait
de la dureté autour de moi quand j'étais
enfant et j'en ai gardé alors
heureusement c'est parce que je préfère
chez moi donc j'ai pu puiser là dedans
évidemment elle a vu le film batman oui
et alors elle a trouvé ben on se parle
pas c'est un peu comme dans le film oui
nous on se parle pas beaucoup donc elle
a dit qu'est ce qu'elle a dit elle a dit
vous avez déclaré s'il ya vu un papa une
maman classique qui vous aiment chine
avait appelé mon bébé chéri toute la
journée j'aurais été quelqu'un d'autre
ah oui bah oui évidemment je pars trop
près de risque en disant ça non je n'ai
pas moi je crois que voilà les parents
c'est extrêmement important là quand on
rencontre quelqu'un il faudra pas lui
demander que tu fais comme métier vrai
dire qu'est ce que ta mère donc mer
qu'est ce que c'est dès qu'on prend cinq
minutes ça explique beaucoup de choses
donc si on pouvait s'attaquer au 21ème
siècle ou au mythe de l'amour maternel
ça serait intéressant c'est vrai quand
vous étiez petit quand vous avez couché
chez les copines pitié affreusement
étonné de voir que finalement ils
s'embrassent et le soir avant de se
coucher mais il se réveiller le matin
ils sont assez nouveau pour déneigement
awek a cédé ses amis ça me faisait ben
oui quand on connaît pas ça fait moi je
pensais que c'était c'était partout
comme chez moi quand je disais ils sont
bizarres ces gens deviennent des 100
brasse et le matin un médecin et des
chevilles et pour mes parents c'est
encore plus bizarre qu'est ce qu'on a
c'est en gros c'était d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas en gros c'était marrant ces
gens qui parce que revenait jeu léché la
gueule ya peut-être d'autres choses à
faire alors quand on connaît pas seysses
et voilà on est étranger mais c'est
parce que vous avez mis tout ça dans
peut-être le film et bien non je crois
la télécharger pas mis de quelqu'un
d'autre en tout cas mis deux mois
on voit que t'es pas une vraie migrer
toi c'est comme ça qu'on fait ça du bout
des doigts la bouche en cul-de-poule de
parcourir beaucoup de l'année on est la
meilleure équipe de nettoyage depuis
deux ans j'ai arrêté
je t'avais arrêté le choix pour trouver
un squat a fait plus d'une semaine que
tu as encore là aujourd'hui tu te casses
têtes connues ok
sur les oreilles toute la journée témoin
entendu par écraser
pas le garder avec levante et à la nuit
et que fait on quand tu travailles
philly doit partir aujourd'hui
j'ai tout mangé oui
j'attendais ça
muromachi pas
raciste c'est pour faire chier les
étrangers que tu as choisi ce métier
minable toutes les félicitations vous
avez une excellente équipe mais ça tient
à vous vous savez les mener c'est pas
une bonne course pointe ça c'est des dix
considèrent que tout vous faire dire et
ou quoi n'oublie pas qu'il ya plein de
filles chez nous qui voudraient prendre
ta place les flics je sais pas dit très
bien malika marnier la gauche de se
planquer
[Musique]
quand tu as une motion laisse pas aller
plus à
blâmer
[Musique]
maryline de miliciens est avec nous
on fait venir une autre couleur
naturelle la plus élevée c'est plus dur
bryn c'est plus dur quand j'ai vu le
jour dans une émission de chez daniela
lumbroso sur un sur lci et alors un
moment elle était interloquée parce que
vous avez dit et je crois que c'est un
peu le coeur du film vous avez dit être
tolérant c'est aimer un raciste pas
parce qu'il est raciste et parce que
c'est un être humain et elle n'a pas
compris la lancer la pub et je crois que
non mais non mais je veux dire c'est
vrai la compassion c'est ça quand le
pape va pardonner ali agça qui lui a
tiré des balles dans le ventre c'est
pareil bon c'est vrai que moi je cherche
toujours à comprendre matériel puisque
condamné je sais pas
souvent la tolérance et les à sens
unique c'est vrai que c'est mieux si
marilyn par exemple dans le film à un
moment bon à la sa carte du front
national c'est parce qu'elle ait pas
d'autres solutions pour trouver du
boulot je dirais c'est pas parce que les
nazis c'est parce qu'elle est raciste et
je sais ce que je trouve bien dans ce
film rêvé tout à fait même le pur et dur
qui m'intéresse c'est savoir je vais
devoir m'asseoir lui dire comment il en
est arrivé là et comment il en est
arrivé là il ya des parents amis dans
des sketches peut passer des heures à se
poser une question à la fin et répond à
cette question et l âge sont célèbres ou
pas ben oui c'est qu'on a une conviction
de ses terres et je crois que tata ça
sent ça ouais ou pas
c'est d'être capable d'envisager le
point de vue de l'autre où passaient
diakaye à bulles
compliqué qu'on leur disait y avait
quelqu'un qui habite rayonner tous le
compte quelque 1 on est tous l'étranger
de quelqu'un enfin bon bref on sait bien
que sa main vous dit chez nous pas aller
bien quand j'étais petit palais bien
c'était inconcevable seul remède contre
le cafard c'était de faire le tour du
pâté de maisons c'était marche ou crève
et là vers l'âge de 5 6 ans vous
découvrez que finalement le rire peut
sauver les pires moments et quand vous
êtes à l'arrière de la voiture je régime
que chez vous on a les détroits donc on
imagine bien les deux mots pet à côté de
moi ça un émoi au milieu moi je vomis
vous aviez faire des tours en voiture
j'imagine sa balade on allait dans l'âme
à montbrison la ola le village un peu
plus petit que cette le ciel venait voir
les amis des jeunes est là et là vous
découvrez en fait que dans la voiture ou
dit des vannes ça fait marrer tout le
monde donc et vous dites je me sentais
responsable de leur bonheur à tous oui
c'est exactement ça responsable j'avais
cette responsabilité là il alors à
l'époque un peu comme dans marilyn
lamari vif évidemment les coûts de joe
dassin en se mettant sa veste blanche et
sa chemise blanche vous vous enfermez
dans votre chambre avec al jarreau barry
white et stevie wonder c'est vrai que je
crois que je me suis chouchoutée à ça en
fait ouais parce que de
12 ans à 17 ans qu'on le déjeuner
était dure à peu près un quart d'heure
ce n'est pas par plaisir donc on mange
pour manger qua non que ça dure dix
minutes à tout casser un quart d'heure
et après donc jusqu'à jusqu'à la
sonnerie de l'école que j'entendais chez
moi c'est vrai je mettais tout c'est
voilà tout ça j'étais j'arrivais en
classe sous les c'est une drogue saoulé
avec eux sans terre et vesa pour ce
pauvre tenir le coup il y avait ça y
avait le rire évidemment et à paris dire
que d'un seul coup comme beaucoup
d'entre nous vous dites je vais monter à
paris parce que là où toute façon tout
est possible donc vous arrivez ici est
la première chose que vous faites en
arrivant on en voit bien là la fille de
marchand de chaussures qui en avait
marre de porter les pompes qu'on lui
faisait m vous acheter des bottes je me
suis acheter des bottes magnifique c'est
marrant ce que c'est exactement les
votes qu'on fait maintenant le fait
grise très pointu sabine un truc de
thestreet allons comme cette menace
était plus basse et plus branché
saint-etienne avait pas des modèles
comme ça des talons de 10 centimètres
pointu donc j'étais très embêté d'aller
pour la première fois dans un et je me
souviens j'ai laissé un pourboire la
fille parce que vend des chaussures
c'est pas vendre les c'est difficile des
chaussures qui vont acheter des
chaussures ils sont insupportables et
jean soir fait mal aux pieds zemp à la
coulée à elles sont trop longues à park
ride me machin on y va pour se baisser
et ses cartons sa tombe sinon quelqu'un
qui se met à vous le pied non ça me gêne
faire tremper mes parents alors à paris
vous arrivez au cours florent pour
préparer le conservatoire et vous êtes
reçu première à l'entrée du
conservatoire et le faisait michel
bouquet comme prof c'est pas mal pas mal
hein c'est mieux que ça a eu de la
chance
et là vous travaillez l'aiglon agrippine
ce qui fait que finalement quand on
quand on vous voit dans marilyn les gens
ont l'impression que c'est comme ça un
truc qui vous a pris un jour j'arrête de
faire de la scène je vais faire du
cinéma en fait j'ai commencé comme ça
alors est ce que finalement le comique
ça a été une parenthèse mais c'est
incroyable cette histoire vous êtes
parti de l'âne on va voir comment j'ai
jamais pensé moi j'ai rien dit tiens je
vais partir de cet été pour faire ça
c'est pas c'est pas et je me suis
retrouvé quand on va faire ça on
m'aurait dit ça va durer 12 ans j'aurais
dit mais comment mais alors qu'est ce
que je devais faire donc je vais rater
plein de trucs donc j'étais dans la
grotte dans le voyage et comme voilà
dans ces familles aussi je commence
quand on finit cependant ce qu'on a
commencé à tout ça mais c'est pas des
paroles c'est vrai bien s'ils ont créé
ces abrutis de faire autrement et alors
là il ya un truc que difficile à
comprendre pourquoi c'est un coup de
blues à la fin du conservatoire pourquoi
vous rentrez pas dans une troupe de
théâtre
vous partez à saint-etienne revendre des
chaussures ça s'est un peu voilà c'était
dur le jour vous êtes reparti non c'est
de rester qu'il
est là vous allez en amérique centrale
mais comment tout seul non je m'arrête à
un ami que je débouche avec un sac à dos
et tout mais voilà et on part pour deux
mois et je me dis bah voilà et quand je
reviens je vais la vie c'est ça ouais
donc tu vas travailler un peu faire tu
t'en fous et tous les ans qui partira
deux mois c'est à dire que deux mois on
la regarde plus la date on y pense
rentrer dans une chapelle ou oui le
temps est complètement c'était en 80 je
n'ai plus jamais recommencer ça
produit tout ça c'est vrai que chaque
fois c'est un combat sous les palmiers
j'ai pas dit ça
on dit toujours que la vie c'est ça
qu'on voit c'est pas mieux et cela il
faut par contre souvent
pas
exactement et là on retourve prenez à
tout à zéro avec roger louret les
baladins de l'agenais bouvard le petit
théâtre rencontres énorme avec pierre
palmade évidemment on a vu ce que ça a
donné bedos
et puis là voilà vous fait une carrière
que complètement rien à voir avec ce qui
aurait dû être la vôtre parce que l'état
revoie première vocation c'est la
musique et après vous avez dû faire du
théâtre l'amf est du one man show
incroyable tout seul sur scène
mais vous dites au fond je me sens
comedians et cette phrase qui est très
gentil je me sens plus proches de
suzanne flon que patrick bosso je fais
sans plus proches de suzanne flon
bayonne voulait faire des vacances à la
roumanoff qui a beaucoup cité
[Musique]
marilyn
j'espère que vous le savez malheureux
ben on ne bouge pas
j'ai même répété à la maison ah bon ça
soude on ne bouge pas pendant le doodle
en lumière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la review
bellion bien ficelé mater laissez moi
faire les efforts si à la fin il ne fait
pas le gage qui sera écrit la stran
couilles molles
hockey muriel vous pensez à quoi la
chine ouais vous pensez à quoi à rien
souvent je pense à rien moi allez ça va
être agréable très très tristes 101 je
croirais naturellement que parfois je
pense à rien
grand comme j'étais petit vous lui
ressemblez à qui je voulais être jésus
enfin je sentais que j'étais simplement
renvoyé pour sauver le monde après il
sorti c'était un peu trop de boulot donc
donc de jésus j'ai dû passer annie
girardot si oui je voulais te l'a
examiné les plans tout ça oui je n'ai
pas le trait et intérêts par ça
qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus chez
vous en vous non c'est mais énervement
je crois que ça va mieux beaucoup mieux
qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus chez
moi
nantes est parfois quand vous souriez
j'ai pas lu tout le temps les yeux avec
je me dis sourit vraiment et saurai pas
c'est quand j'ai pas là quand ça marche
les lieux j'adore
[Applaudissements]
je suis d'avis des marchés d'afrique ses
côtés parce qu'il est méchant qu'est ce
qui vous a fait le plus mal comme
insulte réponse à l'offre
sa j'adore
non c'est quand on me dit mais chante on
me dit souvent on me l'a écrit une fois
ça j'aime pas non méchant mais où se
cache ben hur du mariage avec le noir il
ya quelqu'un qui m'a écrit qui a pensé
qui m'a insulté il m'a dit que c'était
très méchant de cham zg celle de prendre
de l'argent faisait de l'argent sur le
dos des noirs
bon quand on vous demande d'autographe
vous écrivez quoi alors ça alors c'est
très bizarre parce que bizarrement j'ai
écrit mme verreault bas c'était ça il
n'y a pas une gradation mettait pas
amitié quand ceux ci
demandent la cie ses enfants je
m'adresse bise parce que
j'ai peur
[Rires]
de penser qu est ce que vous feriez s'il
vous restait 24 heures à vivre 24 à 6 en
revanche pas si ces enjeux des 24 heures
du mans
24 heures moi je pense à rien je ferais
rien subtil j'irai chez ikea je montrais
un meuble
et
24 heures c'est un succès
quand est-ce que vous avez créé pour la
dernière fois hier pour quelle raison
parce que parce que saviez vous venez
ici aujourd'hui
parce que le film sorte est là ça a fait
une sorte de décompression voilà
freinage et cetera une fatigue dernière
personne que vous ayez eu envie de tuer
j'ai pas envie de tuer s'est pas montrée
même pas quand même de temps en temps
vraiment je vais à la poste ou la sécu
non
mais je sais que la pression c'est un
truc comme ça voilà me tuer oui à cause
de la fidh la passe pas c'est vous qui
allez c'est trop difficile pour moi je
voulais quitter le monde il ya la finale
c'était à refaire votre vie vous feriez
quoi pas pareil je serai de la musique
ouais ça c'est sûr ah oui c'est à ce
point là
et jouer du piano quand même à ou ne
rien faire un bon annoncerait avec la
musique que ça vraiment n'y a pas de
guitare batterie ou de voiliers le faire
les déjà pensé au suicide
oui oui et oui
désormais pour l'alim intéresse oui
bordeaux j'avais très bien
si l'usm un peu
je te laisse de trois lames de rasoir tu
regardes que tu vas en faire mais
vraiment est-ce que vous organisez rien
deviner où on parle pas de vous
oui si je ne suis pas assez
non
marine bon
maryline de mehdi charef
j'accueille maintenant muriel robin
auj
et oui muriel ans un triomphe à
matignon
en même temps le triomphe romain sachant
que sympa un peu quand on a quand on
commence à avoir laissé l'enfant que je
vais vous dire quand même les traits
mais vous savez pourquoi non parce que
bon yaya il ya la pièce de mimie mathy
vous êtes auteur avec pierre palmade ils
se sont aimés qu'il joue tous les soirs
avec michèle laroque au théâtre de la
porte saint martin est un énorme succès
c'est ce qui fait en ce moment palmade
[Musique]
flash j'te là
c'est saint pierre n'a changé dans
l'écriture mais rien cette facilité avec
l'histoire qui a fait la parole c'est
pas qu'un des maux bleus donc j'ai dit
mimi mathy la pièce donc ils se sont
aimés palmade laroque vous êtes toujours
très impliqué dans les restos du coeur
il ya eu les trois concerts à à
marseille vous êtes marraine de
l'association des enfants afghans nous
recevrons tout à l'heure nilan moubarak
qui nous parlera de son action et de la
vôtre par la même occasion
voilà quoi donc c'est ça mérite un
triomphe romain si c'est ça c'est mieux
surtout qu'à autre chose on va en parler
après alors on a déjà parlé de votre
famille la dernière fois vous êtes venu
il ya deux ans
on avait fait le magasin de chaussures
les bords de champs elysées en arrivant
fait donc aujourd'hui on va parler un
peu du nôtre famille vous savez comment
on fait
alors cet autre famille muriel robin
c'est celle qui vous entourent dans la
griffe la pièce que vous interprétez à
partir du 29 janvier au théâtre fontaine
avec berlin berne et c'est une pièce qui
est écrite par claude d'anna et leurs
bonnets et mise en scène par annick
blancheteau voilà où les classes le
pitch fait
l'affairé paraît donc l'héroïne
s'appelle irène c'est vous c'est une
célèbre styliste qui doit être à paris
le lendemain où se joue l'avenir de sa
marque qui est racheté par des
investisseurs étrangers un peu ce qui
est arrivé à chantal thomas wallyn s de
la fressange mais c'est irène est coincé
dans une station service par le blocus
des routiers il n'y a pas d'essence donc
elle peut pas partir le problème c'est
qu'elle est coincée avec sa mère avec sa
soeur et avec son amant tout ça ne
demande qu'à exploser et le détonateur
c'est un livre qui a été écrit par la
fille d'irène on la voit pas pendant la
pièce m'enfin on en parle beaucoup et
personne dans la famille n'est
réellement épargné par à part le livre
de votre fille dans la pièce et elle va
même jusqu'à écrire dans son livre
qu'elle a été la maîtresse
était au bon moment maîtresse vous vous
êtes irène est une femme
stressé une femme moderne comme ça se
tresser kaeppelin de responsabilité
plein de boulot qui est qui fait du
business et on pourrait dire sans faire
de mauvais jeu de mots qui est un peu en
panne de sens oui oui mais les dents
elle est là dans la fuite en avant quand
on va dire enfin on connaît ça elle voit
là elle repousse tout elle ne s'arrête
rien ne veut pas traiter les problèmes
et et est ce qu'on peut faire ça toute
sa vie donc ça qu'on a raccourci dans la
pièce mais tout à fait crédible parce
qu'il ya ce livre qui va venir révéler
des choses qui va venir faire elle va
parler avec sa mère peut-être comme
elles n'ont jamais parlé cet homme qui
partage sa vie qui lui disent que tu
viens avec moi washington ou pas bon on
s'en fou j'ai deux mille employés on
verra et à ma montre tout va lui arriver
dessus et et voilà on arrive à un moment
de sa vie
elle se rend bien compte qu'elle ne peut
pas continuer à vivre comme ça elle aura
peut-être pour la première fois une
émotion et sa vie ne sera plus jamais
pas ll va être sauvé les autres je ne
sais pas je ne crois pas cette fois-là
est obligé de s'arrêter pour écrire on
s'est dit ce qu'elle va s'arrêter
c'est vrai ce cas marcher dehors n'avait
plus d'essence n'attend que ça reste pas
de la mauvaise du plomb
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous l'avez fait un défi
au hockey
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour l'essence type
noir encore un peu votre camion là ouais
franchement combien de temps va temps là
monsieur on peut le réveiller votre
collègue maintenant où il ya besoin de
chasser ces huit heures d'une traite non
parce que franchement si on s'installe
dans le fatalisme l'argent on est foutu
on y va on ans qui allait alors là je
remballe après
chiffon chiffon voilà téléphone
allô c'est sa boîte vocale
remarque ça explique pourquoi tu
embrasses la bouche non
moi j'embrasse la bouche en dedans
première nouvelle c'est plus du beau jeu
comme ça
t'as pas dû mouiller ce qui n'est pas le
cas de ma fille mais arrête de bosser
comme une dinde toi qu'est-ce qu'il fait
rire le directeur comme ça
va bien a remarqué aussi
bon soit fils à pleine bouche quand il
aura fini ses poussées d'acné
quand j'étais jeune j'avais la
réputation d'arriver toujours en retard
mais rendez vous ne me souviens encore
tu peux pas de souvenirs tu veux pas à
mes rendez vous quand même
je tue pas en retard au contraire
j'arrivais toujours la première et je me
cachais pour les regarder m'attendre
c'était magique
voir quelqu'un vous attendent c'est la
meilleure preuve qu'on existe
resté deux heures comme ça
quand on s'est séparés me suis aperçu
qu'ils lui devaient 350 mille francs
philippe mon mari ma mère
il la macro était tranquillement il
l'avait envoûté quand mon père aimant il
est absolument voulu venir assister à
l'enterrement elle alors s est couverte
de wallet on aurait dit deux mois après
la marée noire ce cocktail a vu arriver
lui après le bras pour entrer dans
l'église
comme une mariée radieuse à mon vieux
j'en avais pour ses 350 mille balles pas
la banque pour elle il ya une cage et
l'encerclé avec mon père je fais
attention tu compenses avec le sucre
m'en fous préfère d'écart et annule
serre
[Musique]
la vis aux comptes m
[Applaudissements]
ça me fait drôle de voir à plusieurs
ouais on dirait que c'est écrit pour
vous c'est vraiment été fait pour vous
non pas du tout du tout du tout vraiment
c était entre les mains des ming
blancheteau qui a pensé à moi pour le
rôle c'est vrai qu'elle n'est pas
l'opposé de moi parce que
je crois qu'on a la même
carrure énergie peut-être force ya de la
force cette même mais après non je ne
suis pas allée j'aurais pas si j'étais
elle un peu plus je crois mais déjà
longtemps 10 15 ans et c'est ce qui fait
que je peux retrouver ce mail a joué là
c'est les choses sont des choses à
retrouver sinon je l'aurais mal joué je
pense où ça m'aurait dérangé j'aurais
pas suivre même ce que je jouais là je
vais me balader dans des endroits qui
sont plus qu'ils sont fermés chez moi
c'est une pièce qui était monté très
rapidement donc oui ce que c'était bien
aussi parce que sinon moi je crois pas
que la société lui ça m'a fait un peu
j'avais eu la même sensation avec le
film marilyn heureusement je suis allé
au bout d'un voyage seul d'un voyage de
ce voyage de dix ans avec un bonheur
commande pas quand on a la chance de
seulement 4000 personnes chez les hommes
on est entre le rock n roll on sait même
plus c'est du théâtre ce qu'en même
temps on travaille ça comme du
shakespeare
c'est un truc magnifique ça mais bon une
phrase un rire c'était une pression que
je m'étais mise le temps passe moi j'ai
plus il ya dix ans de plus aussi donc
j'essaye je vais aller vers j'ai évolué
que mes personnages ne peuvent pas être
les mêmes et puis faire des choses
seulement parce que ça marche ne me
paraît pas une bonne raison ça peut
durer ou pas ou vous revenir dans la
figure donc donc là c'est en tout cas
c'est parfaitement
effectivement exacte avec ce que ce que
j'ai envie de faire c'est ce que
j'aimerais c'est pouvoir aller là dans
l'émotion garder le rire élargir
l'éventail voilà parce que je peux pas
une phrase à rires j'adore ne pas
combattre où le temps pas toute la vie
parce que je vais mourir et puis quand
même pour autre chose que parce que je
peux rire ça va être un gros carton la
classe je suis sûr qu'on ne s'ennuie pas
dans cette vieille ça j'en suis sûr la
pièce est forte nous forons s'identifie
à la mer un moment à la fille à la soeur
a moins on connaît ça et puis ça renvoie
à notre propre famille on est enfermé
avec eux dans ses stations-service et on
peut pas ne pas dire en sortant obtient
et moi où j'en suis et que ma mère ce
que ça traite de ça aussi qui est quand
même il ya dossier sur les maires quand
même et on a tous un plus
je sais que j'ai vu l'émission c'est un
peu compliqué c'est différent moi je
sais pas quoi dire dans ces cas là parce
que la pudeur en même temps lancé afin
que la fête continue
muriel robin le pire est à venir si très
peur vous avez raison mais ouais j'ai
pas la voir il ya deux ans lors d'un
interview alain delon
légaliser les drogues douces
trouve l'idée stupéfiante où elle trouve
stupéfiant que cela n'ait pas encore été
fait
muriel de londres
bayal de monde pense que c'est
stupéfiant d'être stupéfait
[Applaudissements]
sa conception du luxe c'est comme les
plombiers style il ou elle sait comment
elle varie ce matraquage
et ouais mais là je peux pas plus strict
mais là ça va mais là je le vois voulu
mettre cette semaine ça pour faire du
social
elle augmenterait les salaires ou elle
réduit le temps de travail à la mairie à
la robin saison mais c'est très dur
muriel robin
qu'est ce qu'elle en pense maintenant à
attendre le temps le travail
social est très chaud
alors pour taper dafri mail préféré
rouler sans bornes en ferrari avec un
boudin ou du bord d'un tracteur avec un
top canon
muriel robin préfèrerais rouler dans une
ferrari avec un top canon les mélanges à
légumes et je veux pas vendu du lot ça
ne va pas du tout en tant que star ce
qu'elle supporte le moins six est
l'objet de toutes les conversations ou
être l'objet d'aucune
leur bad
supporte pas de ne pas être un sujet de
conversation et c'est ok évidemment je
sais pas je n'ose même pas l'imaginer
elle commença bien entendu comprendre
rappelons attention
jouez déjà d'arrêter de faire des
télécoms ça donc je pose alors
évidemment que c'est plus lent
qu'à tel le sentiment d'avoir le plus
souvent raté sa chance
d'être un ou d occasion de la fermer
je crois que comme muriel lou romain
louvre ça fait toujours quelque chose
à bien votre question
[Applaudissements]
me robin ne rate jamais trempé dans
la foule après ce qu'il faut c'est de
faire baisser parce que la partie est
monté sur le très bon après faut calmer
le jeu prend pas ce commerce du sexe est
ce qu'elle est pour la réouverture des
maisons closes ou pour la fermeture des
boîtes à partouze non vraiment bien
pense que les boîte à partouze
c'est très agréable à vivre ici
c'est très drôle il adore dire des mots
que je dis pas souvent pas pu fêter sa
sortie
non pense que la femme n'ont que les
boîte à partouze je me souviens déjà
plus là qu est ce
qu il faut en tout cas la leçon ouvertes
et les maisons closes aussi d'accord
faut tout ouvrir mais alors ma pense
qu'il faut ouvrir vers le bas est elle
même très ouvert
salué à bruxelles
merci mr de rabat
mais
[Applaudissements]
non messieurs
mais quel beau souvenir qu'est ce que
disent moi je les sens passe pas trop
regardante
non mais qu'est ce que c'est oui c'est
vrai que lors de votre première
rencontre vous avez surnommé muriel
robin le bulldozer du rire
moi je trouve agents temps j'entends le
sais ce que je veux dire c'est que quand
j'étais du point alors ensuite il ya eu
la cérémonie des molières donc guy avait
retrouvé un sketch créé 25 ans
auparavant avec sophie daumier avec la
répétition vous l'avez fait aux molières
sur les cinquième molière en 91 et de
cette rencontre aux molières est née
gisèle un spectacle ensemble qu'on vient
de voir d'ailleurs bedos robin 92 alors
ça c'est fait je vous soumets pour
répéter dans le sous-sol du théâtre
marigny je conseille vous êtes tellement
déjà tout de suite pensé dit on pourrait
faire on pourrait faire une heure et
demie et moi on s'est quittés comme ça
il est passé quelques mois quand même et
un jour guy m'a appelé en me disant j'ai
pensé si on faisait j'étais chez
coiffeur avec un peignoir de mach à flot
sa passe est mal c'était les portables
qu'ils aient encore 4 kg m intrigue
comme sa sortie dans la rue avec
nouvellois j'étais tellement aux prises
on est resté une heure au téléphone
parce que c'est une bonne batterie quand
même qu'il a parlé des liens et on a
négocié cet ce projet ce jour-là par
téléphone alors vous avez un truc en
commun je vais faire un peu l'animateur
sérieux mais c'est vrai vous êtes
différent sur bien des points vous avez
une chose en commun c'est
quand je fais le vrai animateur ça me
fait mal vous riez pour ne pas pleurer
la bible ses animateurs télé dans ces
cas là s'arrête et dire auriez pensé
c'est une référence un bon marché je
m'empresse de rire tout peur d'être
obligé d'en pleurer
là la tournée ensemble
paraît que vous avez passé ans en suisse
un tête à tête dans une chambre d'hôtel
jury qui nous raconte mi-saison un dîner
vodka caviar je sais tout
j'attends tout le monde avec lui
en fait c'est comment alors quitté
soirée avait une couleur particulière
pour nous à a expliqué je ne sais pas ce
qu on pourrait en dire vraiment mais
c'est vrai que soit la dernière on était
voisin de chambre s'est retrouvée on a
bu pas mal de votre cahier on était
louis c'est un moment
qui pourrait empêcher la surchauffe est
ce qu'on appelle une tournée en ce qui
vous concerne c' est la plus drôle
d'ailleurs c'est quand est torché
parce que sinon sympa du tout
les cas ce soir
vous allez faire un cadeau à nos amis
téléspectateurs vous allez nous refaire
avec elton oui à temps voilà oui j'avais
promis est pas on va jouer la semaine
ce qui nous a réunis on va conduire ce
soir dix ans après
et
éditions çà skate
un avantage que
c'était bien fait jaillir celui là parce
que les autres je ne me souviens pas là
c'est donc des places sont bonnes moi je
dirais que ces drôles de dames 1
je pense que je vais je vais te gijón et
je te le dis tout de suite mais la loi
c'est pas
manquer alors nancy deux acteurs sur une
scène vide manuscrit à la main voix off
du metteur en scène sans relief
ordures
[ __ ] fumier vieilles vaches je te
crache dessus pauv' con
tu veux ma main dans ta vieille gueule
de but
et c'est pauvre larves vieilli [ __ ]
pauvre impuissant je te démolis
ou cias
va te faire machine et au ça suffit
attention attention il ya autre chose
mon chou vatry en machine et le texte le
texte le texte on va très mal chine est
bien au chaud
va te faire machine est sale con j'avais
oublié sale con et oui attention texte
et enfants va imaginer tout seul comme
ça c'est plat s'est plaint le tess le
texte mon jeu surtout que c'est une
équipe
c'est une telle densité cette langue
c'est tellement un accord qui sont
offerts ont passé la nuit là dessus
attention les enfants je profite que
l'arrivée du jeu long a été boudé une
petite chose ou la scène que le blond
voir bon surtout pour toi h et
je vais bien dégoûté ça manque un peu de
poésie tout ça attention attention la
dimension poétique
réalise les enfants voilà un certain
réalisme d'une certaine couleur j'ai
déjà demandé ce fameux réalise irréel
prochain
ses parts
alors on cherche on tâtonne le jour même
voilà voilà voilà je vais tâcher de
faire du mouv à
l'été
au ça suffit zhan holla holla holla
holla chérie chéri chéri mon chou tu dit
jeune homme s'est pas de job c'est déjà
dans cette jeune il ya ces sons nous
déchirer john tué mon mari nous sommes
des amis d'enfance quand on sait que nos
souviens-toi j'avais 17 ans toi 18 ça
les 920 avait loué pour les vacances
deux maisons mitoyennes dans le quartier
résidentiel de malibu rien petite
station de la côte ouest quelquefois à
tombée du jour tu enfourchés comme de
six têtes et en cash et de mon père le
pasteur qui grimpe est aussi un hamas
aujourd'hui par qui ont haussé les infos
trop longue maladie
l'icann souviens-toi jam
jeanne
faut mettre tout ça dans johnson
c'est un peu court à
ccc léger pour se défendre en vrac
quatre lettres
je ne peux pas épeler
franchir
une cacahuète
non non non mon dieu qu'est ce que tu
fous là qu'est ce que tu fais de notre
époque c'est n'importe quoi c'est une
bonne année
momo matin doit reprendre temps va aller
chercher quoi aller cacahuètes lui oui
vas-y prends ton temps compte d'où
un
2 3 4 5
6 7 8
9 10
le
une cacahuète
merci
la motivation profonde dont geste c'est
le sectionnement abba bon eh oui oui
recommence dont
2 3 4
vas-y tu as eu d'affolement envie de la
capite sur la table de la cuisine et les
moindres est parfaitement sain et tout à
coup le dis si le désir le désir
concours contre
cette
menace
dans ses passes
une cacahuète
j'ai entendu ce que tu as dit que
j'ai entendu ce que tu as dit tout à
l'heure à margaret étape est la petite
margaret et l'éveil au lot oublie ses
deux filles jeunes ça te le demande ne
tourne plus autour de margaret pas
margaret l'étape de mende
chéries chéris mais attention si tu fais
un petit autre sens même si c'est pas la
scène c'est pas ça tu ne fais pas une
scène de jalousie à john brim haut-var
shirin on sait comment moi physiquement
tu te fout complètement de john à ton
mari et 69,2 ya longtemps que c'est mort
comment tu nous tiens oui ok c'est la
fille tu es ah bon c'est
vrai qu'on a je suis amoureuse de la
fille là la
cgtg gt gt un petit peu gêné seat et
c'est mieux comme ça c'est plus
sur les autres années au sein d'un
ensemble est ce le coup reprend du
souffle et du monde vous plaît du monde
hors d'air sa note d'humour dumont rang
des [ __ ] hors des salles à paris
mardi
non
bravo
bibeau
le sketch les a
avant le spectacle de 92 bravo merci
beaucoup alors muriel bas donc en ce
moment effectivement vous n'êtes pas sur
scène donc voilà il ya deux spectacles
avec lui par vous qu'on peut voir ja
j'adore papoter avec vous donc avec
mimie mathy vous avez co écrit ça toutes
les deux et ils se sont aimés évidemment
j'ai coécrit et pierre palmade et qui
jouait en ce moment sur scène par pierre
palmade et michèle laroque je sais bien
que vous soyez tous les bassins c'est
fantastique ça serait bien si ça
vachement le cube tu peux parler c'est
vrai c'est mon côté c'est quand même une
des femmes les plus drôles que nous
ayons et elle peut être également
émouvante quand même dans la vie
là par là tu vois par exemple la façon
dont on est là dans le rozel habilleuse
rattraper
merci muriel ouest avec nous
me revient de rabat
bonsoir montréal on s'en tirait ses vins
est ce que tu as fait quoi ce truc ce
bracelet c'est samuel benchetrit qui me
l'a offert
pourquoi ça veut dire quoi j'avais gagné
là bas j'ai vu un peu
on
se bat bien mais qu'est ce qu'en pensent
leurs gammes c'est bien mais bien ça
casse un peu le look l'actrice coup que
je peux avoir pendant la semaine d'être
ça fait rebelles bonsoir et bk alors
quel est ton actualité rebecca
ces familles
prononcé tokyo famille alors muriel
robin vous avez déclaré au quotidien
belge la dernière heure le 7 décembre
2005 la télévision je déteste la preuve
j'en ai même pas chez moi les plateaux
je me rends uniquement parce qu'il le
faut pour la promotion à la télé il faut
faire rire immédiatement en se mettant
au service d'un animateur
nécessairement drôles ou talentueux
conclusion je n'aime pas ce que ces
touristes vous qu'est ce que
c'est mal tourné parce que c'est
beaucoup
c'est plus doux que ça si vous aviez dit
et plus doux que ça je sais pas faux
vous avez raison de fissures non je
n'aime pas la télé je crois que parce
que j'ai pas parce qu'on peut pas avoir
du talent partout et il faut en avoir là
aussi que le texte n'est pas préparé et
que voilà il faudra du talent aussi
parce qu'encore vous passez beaucoup de
gens qui vous regardent et que voilà et
qu'à la sortie on peut vous dire que je
trouvais bien ou pas bien tu as dit sa
patte donc on est encore au front et
c'est moins facile je veux dire merial
en 2000 visiteurs et noyades en avoir
fini avec le one woman show avec les
sketches pour vous consacrer au théâtre
et au cinéma vous avez changé la vie
vous êtes revenu avec un spectacle sans
sketch c'est peut-être le cinéma qui a
changé d'avis un spectacle chants
sketches ans est passé de 10 avec les
sketches et j'ai arrêté les sketchs
jeudi je fais je sais pas
si j'arrêtais les sketchs voilà que ce
soit votre spectacle au secours coécrit
avec pierre palmade
c'est pas une succession de sketches ces
deux heures dans la vie d'une femme qui
a eu l'idée de monter blanche neige et
les sept nains en comédie musicale
on est à 15 jours de la première autour
d'elle tout s'agite et en suisse le
personnage comme ça lisa qui parle à 19
personnes qui sont pas là c'est assez
pratique parce que vous avez une fois me
dit je me cogne pas une comédienne qui
jouerait estelle et qui mettrait six
secondes à sortir avec c'est formidable
ça va très vite ça va très vite la
personne est là et on nous demande
d'aller sortie pour le rythme parce que
c'est très important ça compte beaucoup
pour moi c'est un rythme
voilà il ya du bon dans le fait d'être
salsa près avec les personnages et tu
attendais les répliques avec guy bedos
attendait
tant des commissions tu revenais il ya
dix-neuf personnes puisque 19
personnages imagine à 19,6 vous étaient
tous là on s'emmerderait j'en suis un
mais on sent à peine seconde alors vous
jouez vous chantez vous dansez vous avez
sibold autour de vous et c'est trés
procédure à faire ce que vous faites là
ce qui est dur c'est de rester 1h50 avec
que des mots avec 4000 personnes faire
que le temps s'arrête être drôle des
choses qui ne le sont pas et être son
propre héros aixois entendant une barre
à chaque force 10 en excès a l'air
d'être facile c'est cette difficulté qui
ne voit qu on ne voit pas qui rend c'est
de ce métier beau mais qui fait que
c'est que ça reste à faire tous les
soirs et c'est aussi difficile tous les
soirs c'est difficile à chaque fois un
9-2 oui de faire partout tout le temps
là on a voulu de les tenir de ne pas les
perdre d'être voilà au millimètre ces
édifices oui j'en riais que c'est
difficile mais parce que j'ai choisi que
ce soit difficile parce que sinon je
m'ennuierais vous avez quatre cinq mille
personnes tous les soirs au total 300
mille spectateurs mais cette fois
c'était fin j'en est à 424 me mais qu'il
omet 400 même pour tous combien de
personnes par kilomètre et alors le dvd
lui il est pré vendu à 300 mille
exemplaires ce que vous allez faire un
million de 1 million de dvd quoi on sait
pas si ça existe ça a réussi six gardes
et jamel il faut un million ces
pavillons dvd à 20 euros le dvd muriel
je compte
redonner à l'afrique aussi aux balles
normales voilà si l'asie c'est énorme
alors on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
je vais regarder votre caméra new york
c'est le cas le rouge oui et vous allez
dire magnéto serge loigne et ou
bien
maman est venue nous voir et puis haut
de gamme merci qu'elle se soit souvenez
du bilan du théâtre coup de bol alors
pourquoi au regard des moments comme ça
et oui c'est vrai l'habitude moment est
ailleurs c'est vrai est aujourd'hui
maman est en robe de chambre on s'en
fout quoi quoi voilà comment moment
nadine annonce n'est pas grave non j'ai
pas demain ni après-demain pas lui a plu
la guide nadine nadine nadine nous dit
voilà
papa
papa et
voilà il est au restaurant
pourquoi marinette miroir mon beau
miroir
je suis toujours là plus bas
la fia va pas du tout du tout du tout du
toit
non c'est pas cohérent le haut c'est
hamilton le passé botero
dirais pas que c'est un bon terreau
écouter jette plus clair on à la fleur
en bas rhône alpes au
ça va pas encore une fois vous n'êtes
pas dans l'ordre enfin pour être dans
l'ordre c'est pas compliqué vous devez
vous souvenir du derrière que vous avez
devant vous ce qui veut dire quatre
shows bonsu des dormeurs qui pensent eux
que de joyeux qui pensent que de simples
flec on s'occupe grincheux qui pensent
que tim hill qui pensent aucune preuve
qui leur profil pensons que qui veut je
m'en fous les personnes de ma maman
moment non maman même quand elle me dit
que marie-claude azizi
maman moment oui moment-même capte elle
me dit qu'elle ne me quittera jamais
maman maman non maman même quand je lui
dis tu es la femme de ma vie je mens à
maman non maman je t'aime
qui
longtemps la barre
avec
on sait qu'il va mourir
tu marches morphine
et vous que ma fiancée un mot si vous
avez bien entendu ma plus loin fiancée
voilà ma fiancée a eu une aventure avec
eric un homme bon il faut juste savoir
serrières moi je suis depuis quatre ans
avec nadine mais avant on était restés
quatre ans avec un homme qui le même
eric le susdit ou subie le mouvement des
trucs alors tu m'étonnes que je passe ta
gueule est-ce que du roumois d'ailleurs
pourquoi on m'a très politique sur la
fiche parce qu'à ce qu'il a pété la lui
j'aime mais y aurait eu ce spectacle
pourquoi parce que ce n'est pas fait la
connerie d'habiter ensemble serait pas
les voyeurs un beau du coup j'aurais pas
fait une dépression si j'ai pas fait une
dépression sommes remontés blanche neige
en comédie musicale c'est pas folle
[Musique]
au château
1h50 de bonheur
oui
elle a quand même une vie privée assez
compliqué sa mère est atteinte de la
maladie d'alzheimer sa fiancé s'appelle
nadine alors concernant votre mère c'est
autobiographique
pendant qu'elle était malade vous êtes
parti pendant un an à son chevet dans
l'appartement de votre enfance et à
saint-etienne est pas possible de vous
deux vous décollez dalle qua non
non parce que
quand on sent quand on sait pas
d'ailleurs cette maladie on ne sait pas
que ça va faire mourir donc c'est pas
son reste parce qu'on sent que mais
cette maladie en tout cas je fais que
l'eia lâcher prise de la part des gens
qui l'ont et ma mère qui était plutôt
quelqu'un de dur enfin de voilà qui
était vaincue devant la dureté avait
lâché donc elle était menthe et et c'est
sous ce qu'on a envie de le prendre et
puis et puis
une phrase terrible dit on perd la
personne mais elle est encore vivant oui
c'est terrible ce terrible
les mots pour expliquer ça parce que
c'est vrai qu'on devrait aller plus là
on leur ferait un deuil elle est là et
on se dit tous les matins on serait rien
me suis dit je vais faire comme je manie
que je vais faire un petit retour
arrière et puis ça va marcher parce que
parce que parfois ça marche donc taquet
bien pourquoi ça marche mais parfois ça
marche qu'on est là et c'est les éclairs
de lucidité un moment il y en a plus du
tout et puis on n'a plus du tout quand
maman le jour où ma mère maggie
q c'est wayne muriel
j'écoute j'ai vécu une chose que
j'entendais cette expression le sang qui
se glace j'avais connu ça j'ai eu le son
qui s'est glacé c'est un truc bon voilà
donc qui après il ya plus jamais ça
connect plus est la personne n'est plus
là et plus alors voilà le plus là alors
à l'issue de cette aventure tragique
vous avez connu une dépression assez
grave oui oui j'étais très mal quand
j'avais un peu un moment j'étais les
yeux au plafond et je m'en sortirais pas
quoi oui ma mamma grand soir à défaut la
même clinique psychiatrique
fonds peut pas laisser comme ça je ça
marchait plus
je n'étais plus donc on a misé
au bon endroit dans un village
d'ailleurs j'avais fait ma terminale
donc souvenirs souvenirs peu importe et
et puis basse et voilà il des gens dont
c'est le métier les psys tout simplement
des choses bêtes comme vous forcer à
prendre une douche en vous disant c'est
avec de l'eau chaude parce que ça active
le sens et ça voilà des gens des mots
mais surtout ça et après avoir eu un
mois et demi deux cliniques
psychiatriques
gg j'étais debout voilà vous a proposé
d'écrire un livre à ce moment là oui
après peu après j'ai commencé à mettre
des mots sur ça je les ennemis
d'ailleurs et et je dirais que ce qui
est intéressant dans cette écriture
parce que la bonne écriture peut-être
s'ils voient quelque chose à dire
d'intéressant c'est quand y en a plus du
tout censure l'autocensure
tant qu'il ya quelque chose qui sorte
elle est comme ça donc j'ai pu balancer
40 pages qui sont je crois qu'à un
moment c'est ni bien ni pas bien quand
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
comme si le c'est comme si on regarde le
coeur et comment y êtes dedans et puis
ça m'a fait aller mieux aussi ça et un
moment c'est drôle parce que je devais
aller mieux et puis j'ai voulu écrire
j'ai commencé à regarder ce que
j'écrivais très sensuelle et là j'ai pu
écrire ce que je te disais non
l'adjectif
en fait ce bouquin si vous êtes servi de
thérapie parce que vous êtes la scène
n'est pas du tout une thérapie pour
monter sur scène il faut aller bien
c'est la plus magnifique des pommades
parce que pommade carton abobo ça fait
ça fait douze quoi ça fait du bien mais
ça ne guérit pas ne soigne pas non plus
nos thérapies aussi c'est que vous êtes
délesté de 15 kilos quand même mais
non feinte gérer le trafic avec ce poids
alors après on va dire des chiffres
qu'il faut les gens se foutent peut-être
mais vous êtes monté très haut là vous
êtes monté à 94 quand même un ouais
c'est fait j'ai pu un moment je me suis
kg de la centaine ouest mais ce fut bien
parce que j'avais beaucoup
oui j'avais déjà faisait pas rire tous
mes amis d'ailleurs je pense est neutre
ans mon attachée de presse louis duzert
pour noël on va faire une belle fête
parce que à la fin de l'année on va
fêter le quintal et ça la faisait pas
rire les gens que j'aime j'aime beaucoup
que ça nous faisait pas rire c'est pas
moi c'est culot moi j'étais super bien
gaulée j'ai fait 60 kg jusqu'à 35 ans
j'avais un accord nickel et puis c'est
qu'ils ne sont pas moins ils
représentent ce qui n'est pas à moi
dedans quand j'enlève j'enlève j'enlève
ils vont partir avec vous parlez de vous
à l'époque ya quelques années sur scène
vous du jt engoncés dans des vêtements
trop serrés je vais la tête qui dépasse
et avec la coupe la plus courte possible
espèce de machine de guerre quoi
qu'est-ce que c'est ce visage carré ses
cheveux courts cette fille qui a comme
ça qui est finie jolies pages avis
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
colombiana boulot à faire quand je vois
les images aujourd'hui je me dis que
j'ai un peu bosser que mieux ça va très
bien le pire c'est moi bien là on vous a
connu plus
vous êtes vous êtes délester aussi de
beaucoup de choses vous aviez des pièces
remplies de cd ampli gleave rempli de
fringues brest 10 objets mais les objets
les dix objets que j'ai chez moi je
n'étais pas très bon boulot mais quand
même les disques j'aime c'est pourquoi
ils sont là ils ont un sens donc c'est
pas mal et l'appartement où il avait
vendu il est en ce moment vous disiez
tant pis j'irai habiter chez line renaud
aussi avec n'importe où moi aussi je me
suis dit ça dit non même pas foutu à la
porte
ils étaient autant la pâte à saint
germain en 6e 6e m²
150 me répondait que c'était important
sur 550 m² mac thoniers
cela m il dit lui connaît
tous les biens c'est très gentil pour la
démone vous dit puisque tu as dit me dit
vous êtes vous voulez vous dit que vous
étiez parfait tous les deux donc je ne
sais pas c'est sûrement mois
voilà sa coupe et donc son carnet de
mètres carrés 190 m² et tu le vends
combien suivant le prix que coûte c'est
à dire 2 millions d'euros 2 millions
d'euros donc si quelqu'un d'intéressé
séquelles rue
je suis sûr que les gens riches qui
regarde bien sûr été riche et ruan 80
dans le sixième end mais pauvre tous se
mettre à plusieurs
après tout c'est un peu quand on est
dorment et donc de millions mais tout
est négociable ou pas deux millions
c'est ce que ça coûte donc voilà deux
millions et à déterminer
vous enlevez tout sur la literie de
danser les gens je les gardais je m'en
fous c'est clair c'est 2009 où c'est
très bien c'est de ce bruit on s'est
surpris du tout genre sinon c'est comme
une maison mais les charges pas trop de
charges
non et que les bénéfices de ta pièce tu
sais ce qu'il te reste à faire y a plus
qu'à attendre petite vingtaine d'années
machete la porte bien dans au secours
lisa l'héroïne est bisexuelle et
challans est passé comme une lettre à la
poste car les gens que vous avez dit ça
sur scène
bout dit ma fiancée s'appelle nadine va
pas choquer les gens pas sauter en l'air
non alors moi je vais être vraiment
honnête c'est que quand un moment quand
il il fallait que cette fille ou une
fois qu'on avait fait rentrer la mère sa
main la seule fallait bien qu'elle ait
une vie privée est la plus pire n'était
plus avec moi jusqu'à moment il n'a plus
pu écrire avec moi quand j'étais seul je
me suis dit bon évidemment l'été avec un
mec et j'étais avec roger louret mon
metteur en scène et je lui dis c'était
qu'une femme est ce que c'est pas plus
drôle plus de rôles surtout ceux dans la
fiction après savoir si lisa c'est comme
moi on peut se poser la question
on peut se poser la question moi je vous
la poserai pas parce que comme vous
savez je suis discrétion légendaire je
crois que tout le monde le sait dans ce
pays désormais oui dans certaines
émissions tu d'une pudeur nous disposons
je vous la pose pas mais vous la posez
pas ou ne l'imposé pas et j'apprécie
parce que ça fait plusieurs fois que je
viens c'est plusieurs mois reçoit sur
les terrains voilà peut être les gens
sont mal à l'aise mais puisque vous me
la poser pas je vais vous répondre c'est
que je prends l'amour là où il allait la
vie est très courte
demain d'être humain est plus important
que le sexe et amour qu apparaît bien
sûr ceci étant je vais déclarer je sait
depuis toujours que je finirais ma vie
avec un homme oui j'ai dit ça le jeu et
bien c'est pas bien parce que c'est déjà
encore me foutent rien je sais rien je
sais rien je suis je sais rien je sais
rien je sais rien mais
dont cosco est un gros succès le dvd va
cartonner et pourtant récemment on vous
a beaucoup entendu vous vous plaindre
dans les médias de ce que personne vous
propose deux films au cinéma vous dites
on ne désire pas pourquoi qu'est-ce que
j'ai qui leur déplaît d'ailleurs est-ce
que je suis trop blonde est ce que je
suis trop gros c'est ce que j'ai le
menton trop trop carré parce que quand
on est populaire c'est une constatation
est un bonheur mais depuis maintenant
plus de quinze ans l'une des plus
populaires peut-être vrai sujet dans la
vérité et c'est vrai je n'ai pas de
proposition mais pas un point qui fait
qu'au début on dit bon ben c'est pas
grave et puis d'ailleurs au début puis
après aussi on dit c'est pas grave on
dit puis on n'est pas ce qu'on a de
l'orgueil donc on dit
ça tombe bien puisque toute façon moi
non plus je veux pas 2 ans finit par se
trouver voilà et puis et puis on peut
aussi un moment s'arrêter puis se dire
je
si j'enlève l'orgueil moi je me suis dit
si tu enlèves l'orgueil muriel qu'est ce
que ça fait et j'ai pleuré ouais et
repérer mais vraiment ce que je me suis
dit à ce point là rien me proposer
pourquoi depuis le dante a pas écrit ton
truc sur mesure
de faire
si ça devait virer et je vais déjà me
mettre des gens à dos si je veux en
faire un vus parfois ce que je peux voir
je pense que je pourrais écrire un par
mois la passion c'est le problème c'est
le désir les autres façons de
les gens ne savent pas mais peut-être
que j'aurais dû plus le dire mais j'ai
fait le conservatoire je pense que je
vais avoir un parcours de comédienne
puis se trouve que j'avais appris avec
michel bouquet oui enfin je vois là je
moi je ne sais pas je fais sur du bois
de match mais jamais de ma vie je sais
ça et je trouve que je le fais plus que
ça ma façon c'était ça ou rien avec 15
ans et vous avez reçu que des scénarios
vous dites avec des rôles pitoyable de
camionneuse qui jure équipe est enfin
pas des trucs rire 20 scénarios appelle
ankara et un truc mais
donc encore une fois là je suis dans la
vérité je dis que ça me fait de la peine
je dis clairement je dis que je veux
bien je dis encore d'autant plus de
liant d'autant plus que le one man show
celui là était différent le prochain je
vais même pas sur le rhin et c'est vrai
que si je suis désirer dans ce métier je
suis sûr que même mâchoire deviendront
un peu plus voilà un peu plus
triangulaire et que
je dirais super en ce moment ça va bien
et qu'on dira tiens ses deux fils et
elle va bien quoi elle est sympa et la
carapace elle n'y a pas de rien parce
que ça dit quoi d'être désiré c'est un
moment où une famille même pas je parle
pas d'une famille de cinq six personnes
mais la famille de ce métier voilà ce
métier qu'ils aient envie qu'ils me
prennent dans leurs bras avant c'est bon
je moi je
j'ai fait ce métier c'est qu'on l'ait
vraiment l'aimer mais motivation mais je
me disais un jour ce sera là depuis
molière on va le donner moi ils vont
tous me regarde et puis je veux leur
dire merci
peut-être ma famille puis je vous dis
merci suite grâce à vous j'ai vu m'a
aidé à vivre et puis ça arrive jamais
jamais donc jeudi une famille parce que
pas de parents pas d'enfant famille dont
le
nom mais voyez ce que j'ai donc
bon mais si ça doit être comme ça ça ira
et surtout très important mais vraiment
c'est pas une plainte c'est juste que
j'ai le droit de dire ça aussi même si
j'ai vécu jeu pendant ses 15 ans
beaucoup de beaucoup de bobos si j'ai
reçu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'amour
et et comment que j'aime ce public parce
que il a été tellement là et que
ça m'a aidé à tenir aussi seul
alors muriel boucherville des eaux vous
avez eu débat on va faire une interview
à peine d'armes
ce que vous préférez en vous ou pas de
compassion la cuire à la jambe et tout
le temps est toujours quoique si vous ne
supportez pas en vous
quand on oblige à ne plus avoir de
compassion pour me protéger parce que ça
va trop loin et moi je laisse des plumes
quoi votre plus gros coup de fric à part
la partie non plus beaucoup de fric
alors celui là j'aime bien même bien
parce que c'était il ya un an 80
11 est une marque enfin c'est le mot clé
des petits de la charcuterie cérons
comme ça et puis ça s'appelle bâtons mis
d'accord et et m'a sollicité et c'était
un contrat en 91 moi ça faisait pas
longtemps que je commençais à est
proposée sur une campagne de trois ans 9
millions de francs et j'ai dit j'ai
besoin de réfléchir et ça m'a pris une
nuit j'ai vu tout ce que je pouvais j'ai
tout de suite pensé à ma famille à mes
sa femme a fait tout ça alors ça c'est
celui-là c'est un texto s'est lui fixé
les dates à séduire le monde moderne
c'est surtout que j'ai dit je ne vais
pas le faire parce qu'il n'ya aucune
somme d'argent qui justifiera tout
pendant 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans et des gens
une personne 10 personnes qui dans la
rue me disent c'est l'abattage et ça
coûte ya par l'argent n'a pas été
déçu
moi non votre plus grosse perte c'est ça
dont on va dire que c'est ça ouais
d'accord le mot que vous dites le plus
facilement merci le mot vous dites le
moi facilement soumis trek sous une très
jolie pas ça c'est sûr ça me fait peur
qu'est
ce qui vous fait le plus rire dans la
vie les gens qui disent souvent sous ce
qui vous fait le moins rire ce qui me
fait moins rire c'est qu'on ne trouve
pas une réponse à une question de bien
d'autres villes aujourd'hui il y en a eu
beaucoup certainement mais bien sûr mais
je pense ça qui arrive et voilà le
dernier
mardi c'était le jour de la dernière
régis lembeye le matin de pierre palmade
et qui m'a dit qu'il allait bien qu'il
avait arrêté avec ses démons et tout ça
en était sorti et qu'ils aient besoin de
me dire qu'il me mais c'est bien vrai
qu'il avait eue m'a écrit comme j'ai 2
bras jules muriel dans ma vie ce thème
là je l'attendais depuis 15 ans parce
que ben y arrive pas ce que c'est comme
ça et là la compassion mais un moment
j'étais obligé de la charmeuse 0 quand
vous utilisez de lâcher ce que je ne
sais pas parce que c'était et ça c'est
un moment et je dis bien fait évidemment
j si tu peux passer ce soir il est
arrivé à la fin du spectacle il est
monté sur scène c'est suzanne non si
c'était à refaire j'ai vu le père que
j'aime tellement revu mercredi
si tu nous regardes
ça va bien merci pour tes fleurs à ses
très gentille et le plus mauvais moment
de votre vie maintenant ouais ce qui
vous détend le plus dans la vie et deux
mois ce qui vous énerve le plus ni
énervement votre plus belle histoire
d'amour
le public
de la grande salle barbara mais bon
c'est vrai comme j'ai et je pensais des
personnes qui ont traversé ma vie c'est
pas grave on tente me comprenez bien que
ça c'est la main voilà c'est comme ça
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs c'est parce qu'on
y met tous ces deux histoires d'amour et
que la vie privée l'an premier bon coup
à la plus minable histoire d'amour et
pas de minables de choses minables dans
ma vie thierry je vous remercie
monsieur l'endroit où vous rêveriez
d'être en ce moment si vous étiez pas
ici m'ont dit non mais en train de
regarder cette émission l'endroit vous
détesteriez trans moment
dormir bonjour vous empêche de dormir
l'amour c'est compliqué ouais ouais
c'est sûr mais c'est sur le ventre mais
c'est ce que j'avais à vous dire c'est
la boule l'a1 puis comme souvent vides
habitués comme c'est le génial
quel est votre meilleur souvenir de
cuite j'étais que josiane balasko et
qu'il n'était pas bien
vous avez moins vu qu'elle et moi
toujours prévenante julien joseph
chantier je lui dis c'est pas bien c'est
dans ce à quoi jean yves vomir j'ai pas
fini de le dire
mais la cage bretonne et je m'étais
payer un ensemble un truc noir donc
marque japonaise intrus j'avais payé
s'assimile balle que stark moi
c'était réglé gay bon mec c'était voilà
c'était alors voilà on va avec palmade
tout à l'heure et j'en suis posé la
question j'ai dit quel est votre pire
souvenir de cuite mais je me souviens
pas jeter tout
ce que vous avez fait dont vous êtes la
plus fière c'est pas montré de faire
c'est pas très clair mais je pense que
s'il était normal c'est pour être fiers
par exemple du savoir que je ne suis pas
pour rien dans la construction d'un
hôpital à kaboul voilà mais je suis pas
fier je suis content
mais c'est vrai que vous n'avez pas vous
n'avez pas d'enfants mais vous occuper
quand même deux enfants avec vous
à pour vous c'est pas qui saisit vous
dire non au numéro privé
oui
oui qui est réparé
c'est un mec qui dépendent janelle de
brut avaient trois fois qu'ils
téléphonent faut pas l'appeler sur mon
portable monsieur
elle m'appelait rappelle dans un petit
moment il est pas encore là monsieur
merci non il est pas encore là d'accord
chez les potes cet hôpital c'est
magnifique quoi ce que voilà on a dit
qu'on le ferait on l'a fait trois ans et
demi de 152 salariés au moment où on se
parle peut-être qu'ils sont couchés sur
metz en cinq ans voilà les premiers sons
font été opéré on appellerait là-bas à
lesterps on en perd bêtement sous
oxygène et c'est énorme et c'est vrai
que c'est pas fier mais quand je fais un
marais les yeux je
ne pouvais je ne regretterai jamais
l'avoir quelque chose comme ça à le
savoir qu'il ya peut-être un moment à
l'enfant qui est sauvé et que
j'allais dire que j'y suis pour quelque
chose je veux pas le dire qu'un enfant
qui est sauvé voilà je savais que de
l'os pour le sort de leur professeur
deloche et eric cheysson et c'est pour
ça que j'ai apporté ce livre thierry
alain deloche c'est des mecs ça nous
mène à la caméra sur nos fins
voilà un relais de loches paul haggis il
écrit un bouquin il parle de son métier
de sa trajectoire on est en direct les
commissions d'opéra avec l'orissa ont
suivi on va faire un film avec cinq ans
1 c'est magnifique c'est que de
l'humanité que de l'amour que des belles
choses donc je dis pas semblant alain
deloche
le héros vous préférez robin des bois le
héros que vous détestez les princes
charmants
c'est grave quoi qu'est-ce qu'on paye
cher tous et toutes non celui là je
faire payer le plus grand acteur du
monde pour vous aimez un way est le plus
nul
banier tellement nul qui se recrutent
que je peux dire son nom pétition a même
pas que c'est lui la plus grande actrice
du monde je crois que c'est moi
et la crise la pilule du monde elle
alors elle est mariée avec la formule
est celle faire
ce calcul sexy en vo muriel
c'est difficile cette question de dire
est peut-être là c'est dire est que
peut-être c'est l'ambiguïté peut-être
votre bouche
comme ça tout petit peu
j'aime bien c'est beau la bouche que
ce qu'il ya de moins sexy en vo mériel
le tessinois sexy c'est laisser les
réponses qu'on n'a pas que donne pas
cette ambiguïté je sais pas je m'en
bourg je sais pas c'est le moins sexy
plus direct ce que vous préférez dans le
sexe alors dans le sac j'aime beaucoup
la partie qui affamant
est-ce qui vous dégoûte dans le seul cas
particulier à vous aussi
monsieur
non sur les terrains rame en solitaire
nous sommes toujours sur terre en
compagnie de muriel robin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thériault et bruno le maire et de thomas
thouroude
alors muriel robin re bonsoir vous fait
un retour sur scène triomphale avec
votre spectacle robin revient soins de
soins prolongés au palais des sports à
partir de vendredi prochain 23 janvier
c'est formidable tout le monde adore
[Musique]
wonder woman dans le dvd dans les bacs
en plus tout le monde peut l'acheter
alors pourquoi de soins de soins pas pu
être poète
ça c'est des questions importantes
surcroît c'était son faux parce que
à oui bah oui certainement je voudrais
pas être poète mais bon c'est pourquoi
pas prout prout non plus alors est rob
route mais c'est impossible non c'est un
peu cela alors sur scène vous êtes super
fit la sur moi je dirais moi
j'attendais non mais je fais très
attention à moi j'aime voilà je vous
l'aurais bien je ne fume plus la jungle
en énergie
qu'on gagne en énergies sales et une
différence qui est enfin sûrement tout
cas elle était énorme attendez muriel
combien vous avez fumé de cigarette
depuis le début devenait moi j'ai fumé
j'ai fait le calcul ça fait quatre cent
mille donc j'ai fumé 40 km de clopes
paris melun en cigarettes comment ça
fait commencé à 14 en plus je dis dans
ce spectacle huit ans et demi mais en
fait la première fois que j'ai pris à un
mégot restée allumée laissée allumée par
mon père j'avais 5 ans ah ouais mais je
vais très bien parce que je n'ai pas
fumé pas bu jusqu'à l'âge de 5 ans
et vous avez arrêté
enlever tout ce qui tout ce qui fait
chier dans la vie tout ce qui est tout
ce qui fait qu'on fume tout ce qui fait
qu'on a moins envie de vivre tout ce qui
n'a pas envie de mourir ce que moi la
cigarette tu l'as eu six mois à la mort
donc apparemment on a un peu réglé tous
à un moment et un jour hausse là on se
dit bah ça sert à rien ce que je veux
vivre je vais pas me fous de ça dans le
cornet et je sens quand elle m'attire
c'est quand je suis un peu comme à la
dépressive que j'ai au fond de moi c'est
beaucoup moins drôle et ça ni moi j'ai
connu extrêmement
dépressive et grosse maintenance une
joyeuse et et fit
mois dans l'honneur je suis devenue
celle que je voulais que je devais moi
je vous ai connu une époque j'étais de
mauvaise humeur ont dit oui à muriel
robin qui vient tout le temps mais
franchement on s'envoie c'est non mais
moi je manquerai pas si j'avais peur de
tout j'étais allé j'avais beaucoup de
boulot mais il était payant la preuve
quand on me dit ça cela se marrer qu'on
pense que j'ai fait du sport je fais du
sport oui vous avez bonne mine c'est
peut-être le fait de fumer je pense je
pense c'est toujours plus tôt une belle
peau
[Rires]
oui c'est pas un peu suspect tout ce
bonheur
l'assassinât il ya des trucs qui n'ont
pas encore achevé j'essaye d'en trouver
ça bien difficile dans lequel comme ça
alors on regarde l'ensemble
élections tout ça sur le physique et
autres fêtes les maintenances qu'après
moi je vous entends ça déconcentre sa
pelouse 1 1 en plus je vois peu près ce
que vous allez dire un genre tu crois
qu'elle a fait la chirurgie est l'été
et que je fais pas la gueule c'est pas
mal reste c'est sur un an donc ça c'est
fait je grossis avec mes salles en
oui c'est ballot ah oui c'est ballot
parce que le tamarin pour pour vos mémos
le catamar 180 places le splendide 400
places aïe aïe aïe l'olympia 2200 places
je vous laisse imaginer à quoi je
ressemblais quand j'ai fait la tournée
de tous les zénith de france et demain
20 1 qui montre quand même à 4000 places
alors évidemment j'ai refusé le stade de
france
sont risqués beau et on risque est là
j'allais exploser en plein vol
il est noir noir ou noir peut pas plus
vers cet acteur
trop les parias dans la verdure on l'a
perdu je crois que je suis plus sereine
tout simplement de secondes quelqu'un
ait quelqu'un en coulisses et qu'un
stylo lâchez pas j'entends tic
alors j'ai pas on va les choisir la
couleur on va dire ou une pure va tout
écrire en rouge voilà un merci ouais
alors
mais je disais brille plus sereine voilà
c'est ça
[Musique]
et
muriel robin revient
soin de soi c'est le 23 janvier ce temps
je suis une tournée j'imagine dans toute
la france oui je fais les ennemis vous
dit c'est pas ma vie que je raconte sur
scène c'est la vie ce que j'avais
accumulé tellement d'expérience que
finalement vous trouvez de l'universel
dans votre intime la toussaint dossier
avec mapa avec maman avec ce qu'on a
fait ce qu'on n'a pas fait de sa vie
l'amour sur le rapport à soi et c'est
parce que si ça avait été comme écouter
parler de moi ce sera pas très
intéressant
alors vous racontez votre enfance votre
montée à paris vos galères votre succès
évidemment et puis avait le toit aussi
vous dit quand on frôle les 100 kg et
qu'il faut monter sur scène vous voulez
toujours alors un petit bazar quoi bon
un peu compliqué ça c'est un truc de fou
quoi on se trouve moche on trouve pas
bien on a dit non à toutes les
invitations pour ceux ci pour cela parce
qu'on n'a pas de vêtements parce qu'on a
acheté un peu que chez les hommes et
qu'on va pas se mettre ce pantalon qui
se ferme à l'envers on est mal chez les
filles arrière ça s'arrête 32
donc on a l'impression d'être un
mammouth enfin et on dit tintin dans
leur entrée sur scène écrit jean
guillemant bravo et c'est compliqué
maintenant je vais bien donc à vous de
faire des shows gens vident et puis là
derrière madame
[Musique]
chrysler
ayew qui se garent s alors super non je
pense que j'ai raconté pendant des
années je suis bisexuelle je pourrais
finir ma vie avec ça avait été clair je
vous jure sa tête 2 2 par an la tête
d'al que j'aurais dit voilà c'est comme
ça je suis mais c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué et un moment on va pas aller
interview d'hier hier j'ai couché avec
un garçon j'avais pas me justifier après
demain on justifie pas cessé la vie
privée c'est intime c'est très marrant
d'ailleurs parce que vous êtes
lesbiennes et vous jouez pas au tennis
qui était assez
bon vous expliquer
[Rires]
sinon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
passe maintenant à notre thé au top du
top
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais rien
n'y a là aucun doute à lionel rebond
soir laetitia ce soit pour nous parler
d'eux ils s'aiment depuis 20 ans avec
michèle laroque et pierre palmade le
spectacle à deux que vous jouez à 3
alors ils s'aiment depuis 20 ans offre
au spectateur les 14 meilleurs sketches
des pièces ils s'aiment ils se sont
aimés ils se re aiment que vous avez
écrite avec pierre palmade voilà mes
idées nouvelles qui suit des de michèle
laroque paraît-il c'est que désormais
vous jouez ce spectacle à 3 donc ce qui
crée trois possibilités de couple
laroque palmade robin palmade et robin
laroque lire le couple le plus crédible
c'est robin laroque
en tout cas les gens viennent c'est pas
mal ça te rends compte que c'est la même
affluence pour les trois spectacles très
bonne idée parce que bon c'est pas à
questionner on n'a pas eu le temps
d'avoir peur mais quand même de voir que
quand on fait 2005 où 3000 personnes
avec un couple hétéro
donc c'est pas mal quand même le songe
est pas sûr que ça se sera passé comme
ça je vais pas changer un bond plus un
bon c'est ça qui est extraordinaire
c'est ça qui est fort mais le couple le
plus étrange de tout ça c'est quand même
michèle laroque et françois baroin
et quelle date que jerry pas
françois baroin qui ne sera pas ministre
de nicolas sarkozy pourrait jouer avec
vous trois s'apprécie possibilité de
casting différentes et la possibilité
d'avoir deux amants coup parce que ça
manque quand même là non non ça manque
pas parce que ce n'était pas le sujet
s'étaient pas dire de venir de présenter
les différentes formes de coupe michel
veut fêter ses 20 ans qu'est ce qu'on
trouve comme cadeau ils ont trouvé que
moi qu'à l'aube mais j'ai dit oui et
voilà qu aucune chance d'en voler
françois baroin dans la sphère
et je joue déjà à trois lui
on regarde aquasar son pari
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti
je regarde à droite
garda trop
qu'est ce que tu fais
[Musique]
mais je ne sais pas réparer les trucs
non mais tu sais bien des cas c'est bon
exemple exemple le séchoir à cheveux
sains ils sont faits plus ils aspirent
alors non pas peut pas peu
il aspire tout ce qui croise un poil un
moment mais pour mes cheveux bercy
évidemment le buffet de ma mère c'est
moi qui le prend au moins tant qu'elle
est vivante
est-ce qu'il ya encore cette amère
chaque fois que j'apporte qu'elle est
vivante
ils s'aiment depuis 20 ans avec europe 1
michèle laroque kpannan au zénith de
paris donc les 20 21 et 22 décembre pour
noël c'est parfait je mets en direct sur
une autre scène le 7 janvier et moi à
oui c'est ça qui est bien c'est que
france 2 a choisi
je pense que c'est pas mal
s'il ya des millions pour pierre
non mais bien et est très content de sa
prestation la semaine dernière ne gâche
pas tout cette semaine c'est pas le
genre de la maison alors pierre
justement nous a révélé ici là la
semaine dernière que vous êtes celle
qu'il l'a fait douter de son
homosexualité
vous saviez ça
parce que je sais qu'il ya des soirs où
nous sommes pas traversé l'esprit que
jusqu'à 1 soit ça soit
et
j'adorais ce garçon temps quand même
temps en mouvement voilà ben non ma
fille je me souviens bien qu'ils
voulaient pas ah bon ouais donc c'est
pour ça que c'est peut-être lui qui
aurait pu dévier mais alors vous avez
déclaré il ya longtemps j'ai eu un coup
de coeur j'aurais bien aimé qu'il se
passe quelque chose vous venez d'avoir
dit ça avec pierre oui oui ça m'a
traversé l'esprit avec le brushing va
alors que c'est un mec c'était compliqué
non mais j'ai sur mon travail
oui mais encore une fois c'est comme
s'ils me souviens très bien oui parce
que ce garçon le talent l'intelligence
la rapidité tout ça donc maintenant je
sais très bien que c'est plus ça
évidemment que c'est un petit frère ou
un fils d'annoncer l'homme de produits
vidéo bien sûr celle là ça annonce un
petit frère et en même temps il il est
parfois et peut être mon grand frère
parce qu'il a quelque chose de très
parfois
très rassurant très solide mais bon
voilà je suis bouleversé par ce garçon
donc un moment voilà il n'y a pas eu la
chose physique parce que ce n'était pas
inscrit comme ça donc ce n'était pas
écrit comme ça mais c'est l'esprit je
crois pas c'est jamais trop tard je
reçois à penser que ça sent trop tard si
si si c'est trois de ses fils il imagine
une date à pithiviers toi non à vue on a
eu à l'hôtel de mr jean de trop
non un peuple heureux dans le frigo une
guerre
eh ben c'est sa vie nathan préféré le
top le rhône dans le frigo
l'atout de ce côté là
le jour le jour de votre mort va tous
mourir le jour notamment est ce que vous
ne regretterez pas de ne pas avoir
essayé pierre palmade c'est un set avant
suzon quand même mais là c'est un sujet
important
non mais qu'est-ce que vingt minutes
pas dire on arrête avec pire on passait
à embolie pulmonaire
parlant de l'embolie pulmonaire
c'était pendant la présente aussi un
palmarès
c'était pendant la présentation de
moumour est assez extraordinaire
vraiment avec des bas mais on est à
partir du 6 janvier j'ai vu deux fois
donc pas le mas vous a écrit quand même
un petit sms est marqué tu as embolie ma
vie
s'indigne quelle finesse il est bien ce
pierrot alors ce jour là donc j'avais
fait un caillou c'est la vie qui s'en va
c'est un truc j'ai connu ça ouais c'est
ça la mort c'est pour ça que
c'est déjà un gros caillou il y avait
deux petits cailloux rien avec un ami
s'est séparé en deux mais c'est vrai que
je suis sur scène je sens que je peux
pas marcher à la vitesse que je veux ça
veut plus je peux pas parler aussi fort
que je veux tous ralenti ça sera mon
titre j'ai un téléphone dans les mains
puis je vais le lâcher parce qu'il est
elle ça fout le camp dans la sensation
et jeudi à berlin en doucement bonsoir
je suis pas bien et puis qu'est ce qu'on
ferait jeudi je vais tomber
gratton baisse le rideau j'ai vu les
gens étaient morts de rire non non ce
qu'ils ont et non pas le nom a compris
moi j'étais presque mort de quelque
chose mais eux non non non ils n'ont pas
vu ce que les choses aillent françois
dure deux secondes et après c'est ça
vraiment sympa je veux le dire c'est
qu'on on peut très vite
diagnostiqué un malaise vagal ce que ça
ressemble pas mal impropre pour
connaître les deux mais si vous avez un
truc comme ça allait faire j'ai fait une
pas y aller j'ai bien fait d'y aller
parce qu'on sait pas ce qu'on va trouver
en l'occurrence c'était pas mal parce
que je voulais me rebelle jeudi je
voulais et c'est normal - machin et ses
morts et ses comptes et ça peut arriver
à tout le monde
alors quelle extraordinaire parce que
vous êtes quelqu'un de très discret vous
avez d'abord parlé de grosse fatigue
pour pas raconter votre vie mais comme
vous avait annulé 29 représentations de
momo ça semblait un peu bizarre pour une
grosse fatigue dont vous avez dit la
vérité j'étais obligé
donc en général les gens quand survint
peux me plaindre parce que pour tous
voilà donc fillon plaques rouges ballon
là on veut plaindre l'on m'a bien plat
dans leur absolu dont muriel qu'elle
sketchs vous auriez aimé qu'on re
diffuse au journal de tf1 c'est la
question alors qu'est ce qui fait qu'il
m'arrivait ça j'ai commencé à écrire une
micro
parce qu'il faudra surtout être drôle
j'ai depuis l'âge de 13 ans j'avais
écrit que pour mon enterrement je
voudrais que les hommes soient avait
enflammé les femmes en homme parce que
mon père était encore vivant si je meurs
avant lui et l'idée de l'imaginer mon
père et les toits physique à la gabin
avec une petite robe chasuble vous êtes
personne mais pourra pleurer
moment pareil
si c'était arrivé là est ce que vous
auriez été satisfaite de votre vie non
ou est-ce qu'il vous aurait manqué
quelques
fallait pas mourir j'ai encore plein de
trucs à faire c'est surtout que j'ai
surtout appris à vivre une vie ce que
j'arrive pas être autre chose qu'un
petit mon avenir encore que jamais je
vous parle est vrai hier soir je pense
que je vais plus encore mieux là j'ai
encore passé en 2011 près de trois mois
son corps est due aux essais parce que
la vie est agréable qu'elle fait c'est
bien la sensation que je ne le
connaissais pas te donc
hier soir mais vraiment dans son jeu
je pensais je me disais bon c'est pas
mal parce que moi ça y est tu connais un
truc comme un plat dont on ne connaît
pas le goût tu connais mais c'est vrai
que j'avais une boule dans la gorge de
me dire si ç'avait été ça toute la ville
mais ça doit maintenant je souhaite
quand la nuit ces sacs tout le temps ou
au moins le connaître à 30 ans ou au
moins à 40 où je voyais qu'il restait
pas beaucoup pour ce plat qui commence à
me plaire quoi mais comme est ce assez
récent quoi qu'elles sont seulement fait
tellement plaisir parce que vous a connu
quant à lui 1 3 des précieux atout
d'atouts avec les
lots non mais ça fait super plaisir
d'entendre ces mots sortir de la bouche
de muriel façon il fallait juste
attendre quarante ans mais on y est pour
s apprend 40 pistes
sonores muriel robin
[Applaudissements]
la guilde est noir
natacha polony
pour détourner un avion tout est dedans
et là à shangai de honte à la bataille
des casques à magna tsb
teclast et 2000 mais surtout d'être bien
fait contre lille et giesbert
l'avocat qui se défend très bien vu mais
gilles william de mahler la belle gueule
qui ne compte pas l'affirmer
pierre lycia
sampler pierre d'issia
[Musique]
très vite des fils rouges chez muriel
robin alors me regarde je rappelle votre
slogan elle boit pas elle fume pas elle
drague pas mais elle cause j'espère que
vous avez causé vu que vous êtes
l'invité fil rouge donc je répète que
c'est en hommage au film d'audiard en
1970 où joue votre idole annie girardot
ça n'était pas obligatoirement avec des
cheveux longs sur les épaules avec des
gestes qui ne seront jamais les miens
j'ai une voix rocailleuse et les
déboires précisément la première chose
qu'on dit en parlant de déni jardot
c'est pas tout de suite qu'est-ce
qu'elle était belle elle a été très
chaud c'était une jolie fille g20 c'est
parce qu'on retient d'elle une
personnalité donc me suis dit tiens 10
foot c'est un d'un coup c'était il y
avait quelque chose de willow chemin qui
était ouvert et qui vous laissait penser
que vont peut-être vraiment gouffre et
non sais pas quoi vous avez un sampler
aussi vous savez écoutez le
qui
j'adore cette chanson j'ai vécu dans une
bulle et michel voulu aller droit c'est
à chaque fois alors on commence avec
l'invité est le fil rouge face aux
mercenaires
alors je rappelle donc vous publiez
votre autobiographie ce maître fragile
aux éditions xo et les mercenaires en
chacun une question à vous poser on
commence avec vous mme mounia
moi j'ai particulièrement adoré lire
votre livre parce qu'en fait on a
l'impression que c'est presque du
développement personnel c'est comme en
rêve se réparer son enfance et dans
votre livre vous parlez beaucoup d'amour
on parle on parlait beaucoup de vos
amours passées parler de votre premier
amour qui est avec un garçon daniel à
vos 19 ans ou parler de christiane une
ancienne miss france vous parlez de yves
qui vous a demandé en mariage vous
parlez de votre histoire d'amour avec
catherine lara vous dites même les
femmes me font battre le coeur
intensément bien plus que les hommes
mais je me sens plus en paix avec un
homme et page 259 vous avez vous ajouté
je vous rassure c'est non j'ai fait les
tests je suis peut-être bis mais pas
polaire est très drôle cette phrase est
à vous
à vous lire j'ai eu l'impression que il
ya un moment vous avez eu l'impression
que vous deviez donner un peu votre cv
amoureux et je me suis posé la question
si ce livre finalement ce n'était pas
une réponse à tous ces emmerdeurs qui
vous ont demandé pour mais muriel
maintenant tu choisis ton camp tu es gay
tête était hétéro et finalement votre
réponse et je suis ni l'un ni l'autre je
suis moi j'aime bien ce que vous dites
parce que oui c'est une réponse à une
question qui n'est pas toujours posée
mais qui est là là quand on m'a accusé
un mal d'années déjà de ne pas faire mon
coming out mais comment faire un coming
out quand on sent qu'on va peut-être
avoir une histoire avec un garçon enfin
on cherche comprend on sait pas trop
enfin moi j'essayais de ne pas de
problème avec ça mais je pouvais pas
dire sur nos sections puisque je ne paie
pas vrai en plus c'est très compliqué ce
n'était pas aussi clair que ça et je
dirais même que je pense que je ne dois
de rythme je pense que je ne suis pas
homosexuel mais vraiment mais j'ai
rencontré anne mais comment mais s'il ne
prend que ce sera avec elle que ce
serait un scoop mais alors moi je vois
j'ai le coming afin à coming out affaire
c'est que je ne suis pas sûr
je
connais j'ai connu depuis longtemps bien
connu à varane et avec anne et ça a été
radical si vous avez vous êtes vous à
hénin si vous fumez pas passé aussi
parce que je n'ai esport mais c'est
aussi parce que j'ai commencé à devenir
quelqu'un de fréquentable
présentable et c'est que j'ai pu
rencontrer alan a fait que tout ça ne
s'est pas démolies ont de ce fait que
voilà et doivent être bien elle n'est
pas pour rien dans mon j'ai tellement
été pire que peut être je ne peux
qu'être mur parce qu'en mode et voyons
que j'allais merkel tout à l'heure je
disais j'aurais pu virer comme ça
parce qu'elle appelle un petit texte de
buch thomas et sa mère
des bûches et qu'on
dit souvent des gens là ne suis pas
encore merkel a c'est sûr je suis foutu
tête de buch avec les crues batlik c'est
aussi une interrogation sur sur le
bonheur en fait on se pose la question
qu'est ce qui rend heureux donc
finalement aimer les filles et les
garçons c'est ça qui rend heureux
finalement et messagerie ville c'est une
chance ou moi je n'ai jamais aimé le ou
la mer ou la montagne c'est impossible
sagesse come back room nathan non mais
la mer et la montagne les garçons et les
filles et s'il y avait un troisième
choix je prendrais tout parce que mon
dieu c'est déjà tellement difficile que
au moins ouvrons l'espace quoi donc moi
je trouve que c'est plutôt un cadeau de
la vie mais quand on est comédienne
s'était pas
fait moi j'ai été toute simple à être en
plus
marqués homosexuelle elle manque à ce
moment là je me disais que je ne l'était
pas pas tant que ça pas que ça vous donc
et c'est pas facile c'était dur a
maintenant ses traits à l'oreille a pas
un film il n'y a pas une lesbienne et
vous lui qui sort d'une chambre en
disant j'arrive ici avec christine
voit dans le film
il ya donc et je sais que ado s'est dit
l'adage sais pas si je vais traiter au
j'avais suivre donc sur les filles ça
regarde moi j'ai dit que pour les mecs
mais mais c'était dur tout seul c'était
dur à saint-etienne et c'était dur dans
ce métier où on peut c'était un peu
j'avais un peu raté mon coup parce que
je n'ai même pas trop quand ça y avait
un peu de caricatures des homosexuels à
quelques années qui a beaucoup bougé
aujourd'hui on les voit fx mariés qui
ont des enfants et ses règles sont moins
dans la caricature que ce truc costume
trois pièces je n'ai jamais porté le
costume trois pièces mais avec le poids
en plus arrivons pas bien m'habiller un
moment je prends que j'étais exactement
sur ce que je n'aurais pas voulu être
c'est à dire vraiment j'étais l'houmeau
de base au bout de peu un peu et j'ai vu
le voyez pas c'est à ce moment là fait
parce que le bois de l'intérieur je me
voyais pas comme ça et donc c'était
lourd non c'était lourd je contemple
nettes manquées voilà un mouvement mais
on n'est pas si nombreuses comédiennes
connu
à bien les choses parce que est-ce que
ça enlève des rôles possibles le
producteur qui a une hétéro et je
comprends même temps les hits entre une
hétéro ou homo il s'est dit attends l
maman helvètes dans les bras du mec
prenons les carreaux
selon la doxa et ça ça je peux presque
le comprend le cette affreuse et en même
temps tous les films
vous
mais moi ma question en vous lisant en
vous écoutant j'ai l'impression que vous
avez été en tout cas une femme
tourmentée
en lutte avec vous même et surtout plein
de plein de regrets d'abord
le premier regret c'est celui de ne pas
avoir fait de musique vous étiez doué
vous saviez
jouer comme ça tous les instruments
coaches et arbitres voilà exactement
le regret aussi de ne pas avoir réussi à
percer dans le cinéma oui qui a toujours
été voilà ce que vous souhaitiez faire
et et vous avez d'ailleurs toujours dit
que la scène c'était un accident qui
fait bien passé que vous aviez accepté
des petits rôles que vous avez capté par
la suite mais je me demande si
finalement votre plus grand regret c'est
pas celui de ne pas avoir réussi votre
relation avec votre mère vous en parlait
beaucoup est ce que vous avez réussi à
vous réconcilier avec votre mère oui
mais les piscines ils sont pour rien
parce que
c'était très forte pour dire à d'autres
ne t'ai pas avec la bonne personne
change le pensant très mal et les moins
attention des tracas bonne personne et
rétrospectivement on compte que je
n'étais pas vraiment j'ai vu des
branques j'ai même vu des psys qui me un
moment je n'arrivais plus à sortir chez
moi j'avais réussi tous les jours quand
même c'est la seule sortie que je
pouvais faire
et s'endormait devant moi je me disais
c'est peut-être fait partie du job c'est
comme ça que quand on n'a pas beaucoup
d'estimé pour soir dix finalement 2e
min et minier il s'appelle on peut le
dire parce que je me suis jamais face à
la france mais je crois qu'il est arrêté
sans nom mais tendant mèze et je le
disais donc cette affreuse on peut
penser qu'avec le gène her2 comme ça de
dégager comme tout de suite je lui dis
enfin messieurs vous savez je suis là
non non je vous
hais le lendemain pareil tu donc la
réconciliation oui elle a eu lieu mais
oui c'est évidemment que si tous étaient
sur s'était dit les choses avec ma mère
d'accord sur dix qui a quand même ceux
qui ont eu les je t'aime l'été belle et
je suis fier de toi les regards et ceux
et celles qui les ont pas eu et ma soeur
qui a 72 ans est née nidia il ya quatre
jours était chez moi et me disais comme
ça dans la cuisine peut pas coller
toujours un moment alors vu de parler de
sa mère c'est comme ça je le respecte
mais répond et vous êtes tu te rends
compte que maman ne mourra jamais dit
tiens le statut l'a drôlement bien fait
ça tu là elle m'a dit j'ai toujours fait
tout bien toute ma vie et moi aussi on
veut la bonne note on bosse bien on
n'est jamais fatigué on n'est pas malade
on avance on est des bons soldats et
jamais le souhaitent ma fille top et ça
quand on l'a pas bon ben voilà donc mais
messi avait mais malgré ça j'ai pu bien
sûr je me suis réconcilié avec ma mère
parce qu'elle me plaisent beaucoup cette
femme puis en fait on se serait très
bien entendu et on sait en plus bractées
parce que mes soeurs avaient beaucoup de
mal avec ma mère sont vraiment alors
pour le coup de différent de ma mère
alors que moi on était je suis bien je
suis bien c'est faire ce pas clown mais
presque trop clown d'alliance qu'à un
moment il fallait que je que je
ressemble moins et je me suis mis du
côté de mes soeurs pour prendre la
défense de mes soeurs et en mettant du
côté de mes soeurs j'ai pris tout leur
mal-être tout leur misère tout l'est et
j'ai été contraint ma mère donc moi il
n'y avait pas un si gros dos et que
cette maman un ratage mais quand même au
fil des années de thérapie j'ai
travaillé j'ai compris
alors j williams avant vous posez votre
question on va regarder un un magnéto
c'est muriel qui incarne jacqueline
sauvage donc c'était lui ou moi qui sort
en dvd le 28 novembre prochain et je
voudrais dire à tous ceux qui n'ont pas
eu la chance de voir le film sur tf1 de
l'acheter parce que c'est absolument
incroyable magnéto serge vous risquez
selon le code pénal la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
or les nous un peu de ces violences que
vous prétendez avoir subi un nom
sous la plume à ventiler la ville était
la table éteignez la télé vite
il m'a frappé tellement souvent
comment
avec des points des gifles des objets
oui tout j'ai même fini aux urgences et
vous en avez parlé au médecin
c'est pourquoi plus de travail lambin
j'avais de l'argent de côté
[Musique]
pascal heurtault mais cette cause d'elle
si je peux pas le payer ton cadeau
d'anniversaire
je vais donc on a reconnu évidemment
dimanche
agen team dix premiers je vais gagner un
prix à new york pour un téléfilm celui
ci est exceptionnel donc des fois vous
dites ah j'ai pas fait de cinéma je peux
des cinémas dans tous les cas les deux
téléfilms de vous que j'ai vu son
exceptionnelle de deux très beaux rôles
alors maintenant posez votre question
gilles william goldnadel oui le
lendemain c'est à suivre et qui déjà
évoqué avec vous pensez vous en souvenez
et mm mais depuis est un peu actualisées
à l'époque j'étais uniquement dans
l'intuition de l'avocat que je suis et
je suis certain que ce film est
formidable je sais que vous vous battez
pour les femmes battues et c'est
formidable mais le problème que j'avais
à l'époque je vous avais dit jeudi que
cette femme a donné la mort à un homme
son mari par deux fois
la cour d'assises l'a condamné et elle
ne doit sa liberté que à la grâce de
françois hollande depuis il s'est passé
quelque chose que je ne peux que vous
savez peut-être il ya un formidable
magistrat qui s'appelle frédéric
chevalier qui est un avocat général de
grand talent et qui a publié dans le
monde
un article dans lequel il raconte que
lui a été l'avocat général devant la
seconde cour d'assises et il a requis
contre eux jacqueline sauvage et
contrairement à ce qui est indiqué non
seulement dans le film mais également à
ce qu'il appelle lui sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'ils appellent les cafés du
commerce ça n'est pas la vérité
judiciaire qui l'a vu c'est jacqueline
sauvages qu'ils étaient outrés par ce
qu'elles étaient trompés ils avaient
pris une maîtresse jacqueline sauvage
harcelé sa maîtresse jacqueline sauvage
avait frappé sa maîtresse et ça ça
faisait partie de la vérité judiciaire
donc autrement dit
au delà de ce film qui devrait à mon
avis va être considéré plutôt comme une
fiction est ce que vous pensez
finalement que cette bonne politique que
d'incarner jacqueline sauvage pour
défendre les femmes battues à une bonne
question merci mon roman oui
elle est coupable à jacques et non
coupable j'ai lu
lorsqu'elle écrit
le papier pour vous parler dans le monde
au-delà de ça tout d'un coup met en
lumière une de ces femmes battues donc
où un mouvement qui se met en place
autour d'elle une pétition etc et comme
c'est un sujet complètement abandonné
complètement délaissé depuis toujours
qui est indécent n'existait pas ou peu à
part des chiffres qu'on nous dit tous
les ans cette année 128 l'année
prochaine 137 avec trente hommes et 30
enfants à chaque fois donc est ce que
c'est bien ou pas bien si ça dessert ça
sera quel dommage la réponse ne l'est
pas je ne pense pas que ça dessert parce
que parce qu est parce qu encore une
fois elle représente aussi toutes ces
femmes toutes ces femmes victimes de
violences conjugales qui n'ont pas la
parole qui est qui qui n'ont rien donc
j'espère que ça ne dessert pas mais je
ne pense pas muriel robin un homme est
mort elle met un homme dit quelque chose
monsieur vous vous dites est ce que ça
dessert vous savez cercle arrive je vous
réponds après un homme aimant dans la
loi telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
jacqueline sauvage est coupable il se
trouve que les gr c est que moi quand
elle est grâce est encore une fois pour
toutes les femmes qui sont mortes pour
toutes celles qui sont mortes et les
hommes et les enfants morts sont fait
une erreur je sais qu'elle ne sera pas
dangereuse
tant pis ça fait pour toutes les erreurs
qu'on l'a fait et ces femmes qu'on a
laissé mourir
bonne question bon bref voilà
raquette d'arrivée nous les que je
montre le magnéto tout de suite allé
magnéto serge
oui je suis une fille oui oui
j'appartiens cette espèce dominé par
l'homme depuis plus de 2000 ans à cause
une légende la fameuse légende des deux
tenues qu'on bouffe et une pomme a dit
le suicide est aussi mort violente mais
attendez c'est pas la mort qui est
violente c'est l'asie parce que le mec
de france télécom a quand il se fait
embaucher de la base ils soient
embauchés pour rester des heures pendu
au bout du fil un pas au bout d'une
corde
les élèves franchement ils sont cools
harris au gentil mais parfois il parfois
ils laissent des petits mots sur le
tableau
ne put
grosse [ __ ]
sa [ __ ]
penser c'est gentil ça veut dire qu'ils
me considère un peu comme quelqu'un de
leur famille et quand j'étais petit en
fait c'était mon rêve d'être comédienne
de théâtre et mes parents m'a inscrit à
un atelier théâtre et j'adorais ça
j'adore être sur scène avec mes petits
camarades
surtout parce que pendant qu'on était
sur scène de metteur en scène ne pouvait
pas nous toucher
et quoi c'est un metteur en scène
géniale par ailleurs
d'accord parce qu'il faut savoir c'est
pareil l'homme de l'artiste donc au bon
on est là pour remettre et c'est bizarre
d'ailleurs que cette indulgence
s'applique seulement aux artistes parce
qu'on dit pas par exemple d'un boulanger
oui d'accord c'est vrai il viole un peu
des gosses dans le fournil mais bon il
fait une baguette extraordinaire
d'abord l'avant
alors muriel robin dans votre livre ce
qui est frappant c'est la difficulté de
se reconnaître dans les autres femmes
dans les modèles féminins existants on
n'a pas de chaleur d'annie girardot et
comment justement parce qu'elle était ni
belle ni moche un peu femme un peu mais
c'était elle vous à tammy de finalement
vous trouvez une représentation et je me
dis mais aujourd'hui les cetc
extraordinaire artiste humoriste qu'on a
vu là elles elles ont pu compter sur des
modèles peut être comme vous est-ce que
vous avez cette impression d'avoir aidé
finalement à ce que les femmes comme
nicole ferroni blanche gardin lors alone
et carling dinho puisse faire des super
spectacle humoristique pense que ça les
a guidés et la première qui ne citait
pas étant florence foresti place et dix
bombes s'est dit exactement ce que je me
suis dit pour aller gérardo mais voilà
florence foresti mais là mendy voilà
donc à partir de 12 ans et peser mes
sketches elles se sentaient
peut-être ouvert une route qui avaient
été ouvertes un peu par peut-être par
sylvie joly mais pas tant que ça il ya
un truc qui s'est passé avec canton 88
ans j'arrivais sur scène est alors celle
qui sont là je sais pas c'est profite
encore de
l'écriture parmi toutes ces filles
celles que dans ce que le travail qui
justement n'a rien à voir avec moi ce
qui m'intéresse le plus c'est bon on
regarde ce qu'elle fait moi c'est pas ça
n'arrive avec moi elle est la seule à
pouvoir le faire
venir un peu le vieux papier c'est
impossible sur celle là même sur papier
moi j'ai dit alors là celle qui dit ça
soit moment faut la faire sortir celle
évident qu elle est sur scène et en fait
avoir
alors que ça pose une autre question
d'un petit car moi j'ai une question qui
et qui a ressurgi en fait dans le débat
actuel
c'est une question dont vous même avait
débattu il ya peu de temps sur le
plateau d'on n'est pas couché ça a été
très violent et c'est très gênant à
regarder je trouve cette ce débat parce
que c'est un débat absolument
fondamental il était question de gpa il
était question de gestation pour autrui
c'est à dire de la question de savoir si
il est possible dans des conditions
éthiques dans des conditions qui
respectent absolument tout le monde de
demander à une femme de porter un enfant
pour quelqu'un d'autre est en fait dans
ce débat là les choses sont montés de
façon tellement tellement violentes que
il ya certaines questions qui n'ont pas
été posées première chose ce qui est
apparu c'est l'idée que
la femme qui accouche et s'est dit
plusieurs fois dans l'émission il est
évident qu'elle n'est pas la mer sachant
qu' en droit mais jusqu'à présent dans
deux ans le cadre d'un jeu peur de bien
rester en quête d'une gpa le fait de
décider ça c'est un choix non c'est un
c'est un choix qui implique énormément
de choses pour pour nous tous en fait on
pour l'ensemble de l'humanité comment
décide ça et qui doit décider alors moi
je vais vous dire c'est que moi je vous
disais que moi quand je quand je monte à
peu le ton sur un char consigny on ne
parle pas là ce moment là la gp11 là
vous parlez de la gpa moi c'est très
clair et d'ailleurs je crois que c'est
garder dans l'émission moi je peux pas
je n'adhère pas je ne comprends pas le
raisonnement me pose d'être extrêmement
favorable gba jeu c'est à cause de cette
mission restait c'est non mais parce
qu'on n'entend pas ce qu'il se dit ouais
je dis juste
l'intérêt était de dire à marc olivier
figeait fogiel que votre expérience
personnelle on s'en fout donc c'est là
où six fois je ne s'en fout pas parce
que sinon c'est ce qu'il y a dans le
livre est ce qui fait que moi qui suis
vraiment on prend donc l'ovocyte d'une
femme on mélange avec le sperme d'un
homme on le prolonge dans un autre
ventre après on va prendre le sperme
d'un autre homme avec le même truc donc
ses deux enfants sont nés j'ai déjà
décroché une
galaxie mais je ne comprends pas
pourquoi il faut que moi j'ai pas
simplement justement ce que je reproche
après mais oui l'expérience personnelle
de marco qui lui aussi dit qu'au départ
il était content que c'était une bonne
chose car c'est un livre très honnête et
il a vu beaucoup de mémoire isole
bouquin normal moi je me pose je me dis
il ya peut-être 60 est cadre dans le
monde 8 certainement pas 2 millions mais
il ya peut-être un certain nombre de
femmes pas très gros long qui peuvent
faire cet acte et qui effectivement 10
mais moi c'est pas mon enfant dit est ce
que vous ne pensez pas qu'en fait
justement tout le problème c'est que le
témoignage de marc olivier fogiel est un
témoignage qui nous parle de sa vie
de la difficulté qu'il a ressenti est en
effet on ne peut qu'être être touché par
son envie d'être père la double parcours
terrible qu'il a dû suivre mais les cas
individuels implique ensuite nous
implique tous mais c'est à dire que ça
modifie justement notre perception de ce
que c'est qu'une mère notre perception
de notre rapport au corps c'est à dire
que le cas individuels c'est pas juste
le choix d'individus libres c'est pas
juste ces femmes qui arrivent à se
détacher à considérer que leur corps est
autre chose qu elle même ça implique que
nous mêmes nous devrions considérer si
nous acceptons que ça que nous aussi
notre corps est autre chose que nous
mêmes donc acceptons nous on est
complètement d'accord mais moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous mais
pourquoi je dis quand même pour le coup
les télés sur le terrain et nous dit des
choses
intéressantes et les ententes quand même
d'être maladroitement mais c'est ce que
charles voulais dire mon avis la façon
je fais auront parfois et ça joue contre
moi et voilà
et maintenant on passe à la question du
7e mercenaires et le cetiom mercenaires
c'est le professeur bernard debré qui
sera notre invité la semaine prochaine
magnéto serge
[Musique]
bonjour marien leur bain j'ai appris que
vous êtes des fait une dépression
j'ai été traitée par des antidépresseurs
mais est ce que ça ne vous a pas donné d
effets secondaires qui ne peut pas
difficile de supporter
s'est pas fait une dépression en effet
quatre dabray et à
c'est à dire que moi je ne peux pas
vivre sans antidépresseurs ouais je
pense que c'est moi qui suis normal mais
après c'est à dire que 100 ans je me dis
en tout cas que vont se les choses ne
même pas que tu te trouves que je tourne
brûle que tout le match et ça me rassure
pas hyper sensible cette actualité je la
suis pas et puis quand on a fait un
burn-out on fait très attention à
l'actualité pourquoi ton à un zorro à
l'intérieur de soi parce que up quoi
enfin l'hôpital à kaboul puis après on
prend une autre structure et après on va
chez les gens sauver la concierge qui
habite pas loin et c'est enfin on se
retrouve et puis on fait un burn out et
moi je n'ai pas le droit d'en faire le
deuxième parce que dans la hotte là ce
que j'avais fait il mettre dans un
spectacle donc ne leur dit pas ça serait
bien qu'on est dans un skate et je
voudrais au j'entre dans la hotte et la
dépression
pas trop quoi vous conseiller
la semaine prochaine d'avoir debré et
philippe even seront avec nous donc pour
évoquer leur nouvel essai donc ça va
être très intéressant on a beaucoup
parlé de tout ça des pressions
antidépresseurs psychotropes et drogue à
soyez là tous à 5h20 qu'un on a parlé
des conjoints c'était lille sept
mercenaires passe à la 1000 kg et
maintenant les faisans faut qu'ils sont
plus équilibrés et inversement c'est
fake no fake
[Musique]
alors muriel donc maintenant on va
regarder d'autres comédiens humoristes
français et les chroniqueurs vont devoir
dire si les infos que la production et
redonne sont vraies ou fausses si c'est
fake ou si c'est no fake dany boon est
un descendant de raïs hamidou un célèbre
pirate algérien oui oui comment tu le
sais parce que je les lui immédiatement
alors jouer comme ça ça nous rue gad
weil daniel hamidou et hamidou ben ali
qui raïs hamidou était un corsaire
d'origine kabyle qui a sévi en 1870
cabine du camion
du fer bielsa
lui mathy s'appelle en réalité ni
matisse car elle descend d'un peintre
qui s'appelait henri
matisse henri matisse est complètement
faux ce serait créée par tous mais non
c'est faux à chaque ferme alors de forel
temps réel m'inscris en faux la
descendante dans les maternelles hommage
avec les ondes c'est fou muriel robin
moi je pense que c'est faux
justement les normes
alors quand il était jeune franck dubosc
à piloter le vaisseau spatial de
l'émission temps x des
chevaliers du ciel ont ouvert un
restaurant à toulouse qu'ils ont baptisé
le cassoulet ça fait péter oui c'est
vrai qu'en vrai ce genre c'est faux et
une photo c'est flou moi je me faisais
pas ce qu'est la photo et parce que
c'est faux il s'appelle finalement
restos
nous font rien mais cela n'est ni pierre
est ce que l'on peut vous intéresser par
actuelle on a compris pourquoi mais
est-ce que vous intéresser aux
chevaliers du fiel
écouter non
pourquoi alors alors dans une interview
donnée au magazine gala
michel leeb a prétendu que muriel robin
lui piquer son célèbre sketch le noir
c'est vrai c'est faux faux faux c'est
flou c'est absolument vrai c'est faux
sur deux problèmes ça ne vient pas de
nous j'espère alors quel problème
il est
noir
de monde
si ça me gêne alors là mais pas dupe à
la clau la touche loulou
pas du tout si la loire c'est que la
bonne raison
il est noir un
peu blanc
noir oui on est pas dans la merde
j'ai lu votre livre qu'on apprend aussi
on apprend beaucoup chez de testeurs je
n'aime pas dire le même texte tous les
soirs ça j'ai le droit de dire ça mais
après être sur scène
enfin en tout cas je ne suis jamais
monté sur scène pour moi je monte
toujours pour leur donner quelque chose
j'aime le bonheur que ça leur procure
mais je les dis moi je fus parquet de
saint-etienne pour je voulais faire le
même métier qu'annie girardot donc c'est
vrai qu'au cinéma ont dit les répliques
trois fois maximum un vernis plus jamais
vous avez plus jamais au même endroit ce
ne sont que des premières fois pour
quelqu'un qui s'ennuie vite va mieux en
dehors de ça puis-je mazars des as à
dire que je ne suis pas sûr que le
service public alors je trouve ça drôle
accepterait ce sketch là aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui quels services unix aix et
je suis même pas sûr que madame robin ne
sont censurés pas à tort pour faire ce
soir au centre à peu près d'accord avait
renoncé fait que dauphin qui a gagné
ford carry trades pas de gagner
qu'est-ce que ça
on pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
hino lardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu